GENTLEMEN THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
HERE WITH THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES.
MEMES EDUARDO GARCIA I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE. AND THAT
WE'LL GET STARTED DEL LASKAR.
FIRST PANEL.
TO COME UP BUBBA AMANDA MONACO
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. IS A BIT
ROADS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
APARTMENT A PUBLIC CAL.
LAWRENCE GOLD BAND WITH THE STEP
DESCRIBING CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR JOINING
US.
I'D.
TODAY'S HEARING ON BUILDING A
HEALTHY AND RESILIENT TWO
THOUSAND FIFTY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THESE IMPACTS WILL ONLY GET MORE
EXTREME.
IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE THE
SALTON SEA CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL RESOURCE FOR
STATE.
THAT IS RECEDING AND CAUSING
SEVERE SOCIAL HOW.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS. THE SOONER WE IDENTIFY
AND IMPLEMENT A STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THESE NEEDS. THE BETTER.
TODAY'S HEARING IS BROKEN INTO
TWO PANELS THE FIRST WHAT IS
CURRENTLY.
.
IS WHAT CURRENTLY THE CERTAIN.
CONDITIONS AND AT WHAT IS BEING
DONE ON THE GROUND.
AND.
THE SECOND IS ON ASSESSING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS
TO ASSIST IN THOSE.
SITUATIONS.
MY HOPE THAT WE LEAVE TODAY'S
HEARING WITH A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES EXIST TO ENSURE
OUR COMMUNITIES. CAN ADAPT. AND
THRIVE IN OUR STATE.
IT WE GET TO TWO THOUSAND FIFTY.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR AGAIN DEBT BEING
HERE IN WILL JUMP RIGHT INTO THE
FIRST A SPEAKER IN THE ORDER
THAT WE CALL THEM UP.
AMEND.
WELCOME.
I DIDN'T THANK YOU.
.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
MY NAME IS AMANDA MONICA I'M A
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
ORGANIZATION CALLED LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE WORKED DIRECTLY WITH
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED.
BY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
ISKRATEL OF ALLEY.
SO WE WORK ON A WHOLE RANGE OF
ISSUES RANGING FROM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO AND.
TED POLLUTION AND INDUSTRY
CITING AND.
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
ISSUES.
UP SO FIRST I'D LIKE. I'D LIKE
TO KIND OF GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF
GENERAL TRENDS REGARDING
DRINKING WATER IN CALIFORNIA'S
BETTER. SO AS WE KNOW THERE ARE
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
CLEAN DRINKING WATER TODAY AND
THAT'S ONLY. ON ON PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS AND THAT'S NOT EVEN
INCLUDING FOLKS ON DOMESTIC
WELLS OF WHICH THERE ARE MANY.
AND THERE AS AS AS WE KNOW THERE
TWO SOURCES OF DRINKING WATER.
SURFACE WATER AND GROUNDWATER
AND THE DROUGHT.
HAS EXACERBATED OUR LACK OF
ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER
FROM BOTH SOURCES AND WE HAVE
LESS REPORT RELIABLE SUPPLY AID
TO TO OVER PUMPING OF
GROUNDWATER IN LESS SURFACE
WATER. ON.
AND. AS A RESULT MORE
CONCENTRATION OF CONTAMINANTS AS
OFTEN AQUIFER IS OURS ARE
DEPLETED. AND THIS LEADS TO AT
THIS AND OTHER ISSUES LEAD TO
INCREASED COSTS OF WATER DUE TO
LACK OF SUPPLY AND CONTAMINATION
OF WATER.
AND.
SO THAT THE HISTORICAL KEPT THE
CONTEXT IN THE CITY AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND OF DRINKING
WATER AND CLAIM ISSUES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. IS THAT
LAND USING GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT HAVE NOT TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. ARM OR WATER
RESOURCES OR CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AS THEY SHOULD.
SO WE HAVE DEPLETED GROUND WATER
SUPPLIES AND FROM AN INCREASED
FOCUS AS CONTINUED FOCUS ON
AGRICULTURAL DEVELOPMENT AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT. WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES DRINKING WATER NEEDS
AND WHAT.
THAT VITAL WATER RESOURCES.
AND NOW THAT LEADS TO A
SITUATION WHERE MANY CITIES ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR LIMITED
WATER CAPACITY THAT GIVES THEM
LESS OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXTEND
THEIR WATER SYSTEMS OUT TO CAN
USE TO. LACK CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
AND.
AND THERE HAS BEEN REALLY IN THE
PAST VERY LITTLE CONTROLS ON
GROUNDWATER PUMPING. AND ONLY A
VOLUNTARY GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT THROUGH THE IRWIN
PROCESS.
AND. AS NOTED BEFORE THE
COMMUTE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE CONTINUALLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE MUNICIPAL
DRINKING WATER SERVICES.
AND I'D LIKE TO KIND OF BRING
THIS DOWN TO A LEVEL OF
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH THAT I WORKED
DIRECTLY WITH IN THE COUNTY OF.
FRESNO AND FIRST TOMBSTONE
TERRITORY.
IS A COMMUNITY JUST SOUTH OF
THE CITY OF SAYING.
A THEY ARE ON DOMESTIC WELLS
AND THEIR DOMESTIC WELLS ARE
CONTAMINATED WITH NITRATES AND
ONE TWO THREE TCP IT AS WELL AS
BACK TO CHLOROFORM BACTERIA.
AND MANY OF THEIR HOMES HAVE
ACTUALLY.
UNFORTUNATELY LACKED A ADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF DRINKING WATER SOAKED
THEIR WEALTH OF GONE DRIVE.
CONSISTENTLY OVER THE LAST.
THREE OUR YEARS AND MANY FOLKS
HAVE HAD TO LEAVE THE
COMMUNITIES AND MANY HAVE HAD TO
GET WATER FROM HOSES FROM THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
AND.
SINCE THERE IS A LIMITED GROUND
WATER SUPPLY IN THE VALLEY OF
THE NEIGHBORING CITY OF SANGER
IS VERY HESITANT TO EXTEND THEIR
WATER SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THEIR
LIMITED WATER CAPACITY.
THEN ANOTHER COMMUNITY CALLED
COME TO A CREEK.
AND AND IT'S NEARING ITS
NEIGHBORS AND AND PUT AN EVEN
ARE ALSO ON A THEY'RE ON A
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM. THAT
ACTUALLY RECEIVES THEIR SOURCE
OF WATER FROM THEM WHAT FUNDS
WATER DISTRICT AT THROUGH THEIR
SURFACE WATER CANALS. AND DUE TO
THE DROUGHT AND DUE TO FLATTEN
THAT DO THE DROUGHT THERE'S BEEN
MANY FLUCTUATIONS IN THE PRICE
OF WATER. LEADING TO SOME
FAMILIES HAVING TO PAY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
THEIR WATER BILLS.
AND IN TWENTY TEN THEIR BILLS
INCREASED DRASTICALLY AND THEY
COULDN'T PAY THEIR BILLS THE
COUNTY OF FRESNO ACTUALLY AND.
THAT THREATENED TO CUT OFF THEIR
WATER SUPPLY BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T PAY THEIR THEIR WATER
BILLS AND THEN THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY WAS ABLE TO
INTERVENE.
GAVE THE COMMUNITY A GRANT AND
THE COUNTY STARTED LOOKING INTO
DEVELOPING A NEW GROUND WATER
WATER SYSTEM WHICH LATER I'LL
GET INTO SOME COMPLICATIONS THAT
MIGHT COME FROM THAT. SO THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE SEE GIVEN THE
PROBLEMS THAT I'VE MENTIONED SO
FAR ARE FIVE.
ONE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
THROUGH THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
WE KNOW THAT THERE HASN'T BEEN
ENOUGH OVERSIGHT OVER
GROUNDWATER PUMPING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE REALLY
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO. TO SCALE
IT BACK AND LOOK AT OUR OUR
WATER SUPPLY AND HOW WE CAN AND
IS THAT BETTER.
ALSO ACT THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
SIGMA.
AND GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN DEVELOPMENT. WE NEED TO
ENSURE AS A STATE BUT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES NEEDS
ARE TAKEN TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
GIVEN THAT THEY HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT OUT OF
MUNICIPAL DRINKING WATER
SERVICES.
AND THEY'RE THE MOST VULNERABLE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE WE NEED TO
ENSURE NOT ONLY THAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE MET BY SUSTAINABILITY COUNTY
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS. BUT
THERE'S AFFIRMATIVE ACTION TO
ENSURE THAT THEY WON'T BE.
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE IN THE
FUTURE.
SECOND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WERE INCORPORATING PLANNING FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
CLIMB ADAPTATION AND WATER
PLANNING INTO LOCAL AND
REGIONAL.
PLANNING FOR EXAMPLE THROUGH
GENERAL PLANS A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS AND LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION
COMMISSION POLICY IS.
WHEN THEY ACT TO MODIFY LOCAL
DISTRICT OR CITY BOUNDARY IS.
THESE PLANTS IN ADDITION MUST
COORDINATE WITH.
GROUND OR TO SING ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS IN ORDER
AND TO ENSURE. THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WON'T
BE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE SO AFFECT ON THEIR WATER
SUPPLY.
A THIRD.
.
WE NEED TO ENSURE AS A STATE
THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE.
ACTION TAKEN TO CONSOLIDATE
SMALL COMMUNITY SMALL
DISADVANTAGED WE WATER SYSTEMS
INTO LARGER WATER SYSTEMS AND.
THAT THERE IS AN INCREASE IN
EXPANSION OF DRINKING WATER
SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES WERE ON
DOMESTIC WELLS IN OUR LOW INCOME
AND I AM ABLE TO. RUN.
ADDRESS THEIR. WATER
CONTAMINATION ISSUES AND WATER
SUPPLY ISSUES IN THERE ON INCOME
FROM THEIR WELLS.
FOURTH IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THE SORT OF INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE AND IS ABLE TO BE.
OPERATED IN THE LONG TERM ISN'T
SUBJECT TO.
CLIMATE VULNERABILITY WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S FUNDING
FOR OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
FOR WATER SYSTEM INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGH A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND.
.
AND FIFTH GENERALLY AS WE GO
FORWARD IN MAKING POLICY AND
PLANNING DECISIONS. AT A LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE LEVEL WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS NOT
DEMOCRATIC IT WOULD TO AND THAT
WE DEMOCRATIZE DECISION MAKING
AND ALL OF THE SPACES ENSURING
THAT. DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
NEEDS ARE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
AND WHEN THESE DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE AND TO ENSURE THAT
OUR MOST ROLE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS FOR THE FUTURE
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE. CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS ON WATER SUPPLY.
AND.
SO JUST TO WRAP UP SOME BRIGHT
SPOTS SOME SPIKE SPOTS OF HOPE.
ON OUR THAT INCOME TO A CREEK.
AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THEIR
SURFACE WATER SYSTEM IS
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE FOR THEM
AND SUBJECT TO.
FLUCTUATIONS IN PRICE BECAUSE
OF DROUGHT THEIR TRANSITIONING
TO A GROUND WATER SYSTEM WHICH
SHOULD HAVE A MORE SUSTAINABLE
SOURCE OF WATER. IF THE
GROUNDWATER IS MANAGED
SUSTAINABLY THEIR NEEDS ARE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
AND WE ALSO ACCOUNT FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND.
TWO IN TOMBSTONE TERRITORY
SHANKER IS CONSIDERING EXTENDING
THEIR WATER SYSTEM OUT TO
TOMBSTONE TERRITORY GIVEN AND
THE AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS SUIT
THAT A DIVISION OF.
OF WATER RESOURCES.
HOWEVER.
THAT'S IT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WILL BE ADEQUATE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT SO THAT.
THE SYSTEM WILL BE ABLE TO BE
SUSTAINABLE IN THE FUTURE.
I.
SO THOSE ARE SOME SOME INSIGHT
THAT SOME INSIGHT FROM MY WORK
ON IN FRESNO COUNTY AND ARTWORK
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY NEWS
COACHELLA VALLEY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ITS IMPACT ON WATER
SUPPLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND AND I'M OF COURSE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMEND WILL
LOOK MOVE ONTO THE NEXT STEP
PRESENTER ELIZABETH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO PARTICIPATE AND.
FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AND THE BURGEONING CRITICAL NEED
TO ADDRESS THEM. SO I'M I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM AT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
MY RESEARCH BACKGROUND IS IN THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND IN MY CURRENT ROLE. AYE AYE
PROVIDE A HEALTH PERSPECTIVE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DISCUSSIONS
WITH COUNTY.
AT PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS BRING CLIMATE CHANGE
CONSIDERATIONS INTO PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN
BASS PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I AM AND I'LL BE SPEAKING ABOUT
THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WITH THE FOCUS ON EXTREME
HEAT. AS WELL AS WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO ADDRESS THESE RISKS AND
OUR WHAT STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND I WANTED TO START OUT WITH A
FEW POINTS ON WHY PUBLIC HEALTH
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT PLAYER IN
CLIMATE CHANGE WORK. LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN PARTICULAR
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGES ALL DESCRIBED.
AND AND ALSO RESEARCH SHOWS US
THAT TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE CONTEXT OF HEALTH
IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
COMMUNICATE IT SO THAT PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT IT. AND CONCERN OVER
HEALTH IS UNIVERSAL AND
IMMEDIATE AND PERSONAL. AND
OFTENTIMES CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE
PAST HAS HAS BEEN PORTRAYED AS
RELATING TO YOU ICE CAPS AND SAT
AND POLAR BEARS AND. THOSE WALL
SAT AREN'T IN MEDIA AND PERSONAL
TO MOST PEOPLE ON HEALTH IS BOTH
IMMEDIATE AND PERSONAL.
ANOTHER REASON AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IS SO IMPORTANT IS THAT I IN
THIS DISCUSSION IS THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE SOLUTIONS BRING ABOUT
POSITIVE HEALTH BENEFITS.
AND SO CLIMATE SOLUTIONS ARE AT
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY TO CREATE
A HEALTHIER MORE RESILIENT AND
MORE EQUITABLE COMMUNITIES.
SO BROADLY IN THE LOS ANGELES
REGION OUT SOME OF THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING INCLUDE HOTTER
TEMPERATURES. WORST AIR QUALITY
AND MORE ACRES BURNED BY
WILDFIRES MORE FLOODING AND
WATER QUALITY ISSUES AND VECTOR
BORNE DISEASE. HAS ASKED TO
FOCUS ON EXTREME HEAT AS AN
EXAMPLE. AND WE'RE EXPECTING THE
NUMBER OF EXTREME HEAT DAYS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO INCREASE
BY ABOUT TWO TO FOUR TIMES BY
THE MIDDLE OF THE CENTURY. THOSE
ARE DEFINED AS STAYS OVER NINETY
FIVE DEGREES SO WE'LL SEE TWO TO
FOUR TIMES AS MANY DAYS OVER
NINETY FIVE DEGREES.
BY THE MIDDLE OF THE CENTURY AS
WE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCE.
AND THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN BECAUSE EXTREME
HEAT OF FUNDS ALREADY IN THE U.
S. CAUSE MORE DEATHS EACH YEAR
THAN FLOODS STORMS AND LIGHTNING
COMBINES. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX CALIFORNIA HAD A HEAT WAVE
THAT LED TO OVER SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DEATHS.
AND AND BECAUSE HE ALSO PLACES
STRESS ON THE BODY IT
EXACERBATES EXISTING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS LIKE DIABETES
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE. AYE
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES SO WE
TYPICALLY SEE MORE EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS DURING EXTREME HEAT
OF FANS.
AND DURING CALIFORNIA'S TWO
THOUSAND SIX HEATWAVE WE SAW
MORE THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND
ACCESS EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
ACROSS THE STATE. MORE THAN A
THOUSAND ACCESS HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE MILLION AND HEALTH RELATED
COSTS.
WE ALSO I HAVE NOTED AT THAT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE'RE SEEING
AND NON FATAL EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS FOR HEAT RELATED ILLNESS.
INCREASING NOT SINCE ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND FIVE.
AND AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
PROJECTS
I HEAT RELATED ILLNESS IMPACTS
FOR THE FUTURE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SO MANY UNCERTAINTIES RELATED TO
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS.
A PEOPLE'S BEHAVIOR PEOPLE'S
ACCESS TO AIR CONDITIONING
ACCLIMATISATION ABOUT RESEARCH
IT CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT WELL
THAT WE'LL BE SEEING MORE HE
RELATED ILLNESSES AND DEATHS IN
THE FUTURE AS A RESULT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND AS YOU KNOW AND MANY PARTS
OF LOS ANGELES AND CALIFORNIA
OVERALL OUR HEAVILY URBANIZED
AND THESE URBAN ENVIRONMENTS
WITH.
YOU KNOW PAVED SURFACES LIKE
GROUPS AND SOME AND PAVEMENTS
AND.
AND LAST TREE CANOPY LAST GREEN
SPACE CRATE AND URBAN HEAT
ISLANDS THAT LEADS TO
TEMPERATURES IN CITIES THAT ARE
ABOUT FIVE DEGREES HOTTER DURING
THE DAYTIME THAN SURROUNDING
RURAL AREAS. AND EVEN HOTTER AT
NIGHTS
AND THAT THIS URBAN HEAT ISLAND
EFFECT ACTUALLY MAGNIFIES I
DURING.
DURING HEAT WAVES
AND DUE TO THEN THAT'S URBAN
HEAT ISLAND A FACTS PEOPLE
LIVING IN AREAS THAT HAVE HIGHER
CONCENTRATIONS OF PAVED.
SURFACES AND LOW TREE CANOPY ARE
BASICALLY SUFFERING FROM.
ARTIFICIALLY HOTTER TEMPERATURES
AND BECAUSE OF THIS BELT
ENVIRONMENTS.
I IN LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE ONLY ABOUT HALF OF OUR
HOMES HAVE A CENTRAL AIR
CONDITIONING SO MANY OF THE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE LIVING IN
URBAN HEAT ISLANDS. I WOULD ALSO
LACKEY AIR CONDITIONING.
EXTREME HEAT IS ALSO SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF HEAT RELATED ILLNESS
AND DEATH NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THAT IT EXACERBATES
EXISTING MEDICAL CONDITIONS. BUT
ALSO BECAUSE IT CONTRIBUTES TO
OTHER AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
RELATED IMPACTS SO.
STREAM HEAT INCREASES THE
CONCENTRATIONS OF GROUND LEVEL
OZONE WHICH IS A MAJOR COMPONENT
OF SMOG THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
POOR RESPIRATORY OUTCOMES. SO
EXTREME HEAT CONTRIBUTES TO
DECLINING AIR QUALITY.
AND EXTREME HE COMBINED WITH
DROUGHT ALSO DECREASE SOIL
MOISTURE INCREASED CLAMOR
PTOLEMY AND THEREBY CONTRIBUTE
TO LARGER WILD FIRES WHICH IN
TURN FURTHER DID AND DETERIORATE
OUR AIR QUALITY.
OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT UP LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
BY CHANGE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CASE OF EXTREME HEAT PAT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE MORE
LIKELY TO LIVE IN URBAN HEAT
ISLANDS THAT EXPERIENCE HOTTER
TEMPERATURES. THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE PRE EXISTING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT MAKE
THEM SENSITIVE TO HEAT I LIKE
DIABETES. AND THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO CENTRAL
AIR CONDITIONING THAT WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER.
TO ADAPT TO EXTREME HEAT OF
FANS AND THAT THESE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS THAT
ARE FACED BY A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. ARE GOING TO FURTHER.
FURTHER WHITE AND EXISTING
HEALTH AND OTHER DISPARITIES.
SO LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN PROTECTING
AND THE PUBLIC FROM THE HEALTH
IMPACTS IT HEATS. UP SOME OF THE
THINGS WE ALREADY DO AT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ARE WE ISSUE HE'D
ALERTS ADVISORIES AND
EMERGENCIES. WE CONVENE OTHER
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS DURING A HEAT
WAVE AND TO ORGANIZE THE OPENING
OF COOLING CENTERS AND WE
DISTRIBUTE PUBLIC INFORMATION.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT UP THAT HE
NEEDS TO BE TACKLED IN A VARIETY
OF WAYS IN THAT BECAUSE WE'RE
EXPECTING MORE EXTREME HEAT LEAN
INTO. CONTINUE TO DO MORE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND SO I DISCUSS THE FACT THAT
THE URBAN HEAT ISLAND IS
ARTIFICIALLY INCREASING
TEMPERATURES AND CITIES.
SO ONE THING THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAS
BEEN DOING IS WORKING WITH OUR
FELLOW COUNTY DEPARTMENTS LIKE
PUBLIC WORKS AND REGIONAL
PLANNING. AND PARKS AND
RECREATION ON AN URBAN HEAT
ISLAND REDUCTION PLAN. AND FATS
HAS VARIOUS ACTION ITEMS THAT
HELP REDUCE THE URBAN HEAT
ISLANDS OF FACTS AND ARE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND THIS PLAN IS COMPOSED OF
FOUR STRATEGIES. SO COOL ROOFS
QUAN PAVEMENTS TREES AND GREEN
SPACE.
WHEN URBAN HEAT ISLAND IT ACTION
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT STRATEGY
THAT WE CAN IMPLEMENT THAT'S AN
UPS SORT OF AN UPSTREAM BUILT
ENVIRONMENT SOLUTION THAT HELPS
PROMOTE EQUITY FOR EXAMPLE BY.
INCREASING TREE CANOPY AND AND I
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TREE CANOPY AND GREEN
SPACE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ON THE
LANCET COMMISSION ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HEALTH CALLS AND NO
REGRET. OPTION THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY
TO CREATE A HEALTHIER MORE
RESILIENT AND MORE EQUITABLE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF WHAT
I WE HAS A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
INTO IN TERMS OF TACKLING
EXTREME HEAT URBAN HEAT ISLAND
ACTION WILL HELP COOLER
NEIGHBORHOODS. SHALL HELP UP
LASSEN THAT THE HEALTH IMPACTS
FROM HEATS HELP REDUCE ENERGY
USAGE AND HOPEFULLY OFFSET SOME
OF THE TEMPERATURE INCREASES
THAT WERE EXPECTING WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS CAN
PLAY MANY ROLES IN CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND OR AND GENERALLY
AMONG OTHER THINGS WE TRACTATE
DATA ON DISEASE OCCURRENCE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS WE
PROVIDE RISK ASSESSMENTS.
WHERE A TRUSTED SOURCE OF HEALTH
INFORMATION SO WE INFORM EDUCATE
AND EMPOWER COMMUNITIES AND
DECISION MAKERS? WE HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE ACTING AS A
CONVENE AND FACILITATOR LIKE
WE'RE DOING WITH THE URBAN HEAT
ISLAND REDUCTION.
SO WHAT OTHER CAN I GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES NON PROFITS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
WE DEVELOPMENTS DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT SAP PLANS FOR
RESPONDING TO HEALTH THREATS WE
DEVELOPMENT OF HIS FELLOW AND
IMPLEMENT. POLICIES THAT PROTECT
AND PROMOTE HEALTH WE WORK A LOT
WITH PARTNERS TO PROMOTE HEALTHY
BUILT ENVIRONMENTS THAT PROMOTE
ACTIVE IN PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
AND WE IMPLEMENT TERRAX
INTERVENTIONS TO RESPOND TO
HEALTH THREATS.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
TRUSTED AND WE'RE REALLY ON THE
FRONT LINES OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR WELL SITUATED TO PLAY A
LEADING ROLE IN MITIGATING AND
ADAPTING. AT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
IN WAYS THAT PROMOTE RESILIENCE
AND HEALTH UP BUT IN MANY CASES
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE NOT
ADEQUATELY STAFFED AND RESORTS.
AND TO UNDERTAKE THESE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
SO WE HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THINGS THAT STILL NEED TO BE
DONE AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
OR NEED TO BE EXPANDED TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT.
AND CLIMATE CHANGE WE NEED TO
TRACK DATA ON CLIMATE RELATED
INDICATORS HAVE BOTH RELATED TO
THE ENVIRONMENTS AND DISEASE
INCIDENCE.
WE NEED TO EXPAND OUR CAPACITY
FOR MODELING AND FORECASTING
HEALTH IMPACTS AND THEN. UP
PLANNING FOR THOSE IMPACTS.
GAIN A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE RESOURCES THAT PEOPLE NEED
TO COPE WITH EXTREME HEAT AND
THEN IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES THAT
ASSISTS PEOPLE IN COPING WITH
EXTREME HEATS.
WE WANT TO EXPAND AND IMPROVE
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY TO IDENTIFY
AND REACH VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WITH MESSAGING AND CONDUCT
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENTS.
WE WANT TO TRAIN PHYSICIANS ON
HOW TO SPEAK TO THEIR PATIENTS
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
IMPROVE PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE PLANS FOR CLIMATE
IMPACTS.
I CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT ON A
LARGER SCALE AND BUILT
ENVIRONMENT SOLUTIONS LIKE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND ACTION.
AND REALLY PROMOTE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFFER CLAIMANT LETTER
IT AND ARE TRAINED. AND TO
ADDRESS THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO CLIMATE CHANGE PRESENTS YOU
KNOW SO MANY THREATS AND
CHALLENGES VOTE WE BELIEVE IT
ALSO PRESENTS OPPORTUNITIES.
OPPORTUNITIES SAID TRANSFORM
COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE BELTS
ENVIRONMENTS.
TO IMPROVE OUR PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE AND TO INCREASE OUR
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENTS.
AND SO THE ISRAELI ARE
OPPORTUNITIES AND AND TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE NO REGRETS
OPTIONS THAT CREATE HEALTHIER
MORE RESILIENT AND MORE
EQUITABLE COMMUNITIES. COME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
BUT I WANT TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION MY NAME
IS LARRY GOLD SPAN I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION WHICH BELIEVE IT OR
NOT IS THE STATE AGENCY.
ABOUT FIFTY YEARS OLD AND WE
WERE CREATED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE TO THE MAC AT YOUR PETROUS
ACT. AND DC DC IS THE NATION'S
OLDEST COASTAL ZONE MANAGEMENT
AGENCY.
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED TO SUCH DUE
TO THE FILLING OF THE BAY AND
THE DUMPING ALONG THE BAY AND
WITH NINE COUNTIES IN FORTY ONE
CITIES EACH HAVING THEIR OWN
LITTLE FIEFDOMS IT WAS DECIDED
BY THE STATE THAT THERE NEEDED
TO BE A. COALESCING AROUND ONE
TYPE OF AUTHORITY AND THAT'S HOW
THE CDC
CREATED. OUR MISSION IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY IS PRODUCTIVE IN ALL
RESPECTS ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY.
IT HAS OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILES OF SHORELINE IS ACTUALLY
LARGER THAN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES ITSELF. BUT IT'S ALSO
VERY SHALLOW AND IS SURROUNDED
BY HILLS SO FROM A PERSPECTIVE
OF HOW WATER WORKS WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE INTERESTED IN HERE. IT'S
REALLY JUST A BIG BATHTUB WHICH
CAN OVERFLOW PRETTY EASILY.
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THAT WHAT
WE THINK ABOUT IS FLOODING JUST
LIKE YOU THINK ABOUT HEAT AND
YOU THINK ABOUT WATER WE THINK
ABOUT WATER COMING INTO PEOPLE'S
HOMES. INTO PEOPLE'S BUSINESSES
PLACES OF WORSHIP AND THE LIKE.
AND THAT FLOODING IS EXACERBATED
BY RISING SEA LEVEL IN ADDITION
TO THAT WHICH WE ALREADY HAVE
STORMS TIDES KING TIDES AND THE
LIKE.
SO WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE SCIENCE
IN THE SCIENCE AS WELL.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY LATEST REPORT.
WE BASICALLY NEED THE PLAN FOR
TWO FEET OF RISING SEA LEVEL IN
THE BAY BY TWENTY FIFTY. AND
FOUR FEET BY THE END OF THE
CENTURY ALTHOUGH IT CERTAINLY
CAN GO HIGHER DEPENDING UPON HOW
THE ICE SHEETS ACTUALLY WORK.
AND THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT
ARE PRETTY DRASTIC.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
IN YOUR LITTLE BLUE FOLDER.
ONE PAGE AT A TIME IT'S SORT OF
LIKE THE TEST THAT YOU TOOK IN
HIGH SCHOOL YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO GO FREE THAT LED TO GO AHEAD.
THIS IS A VERY BASIC MAP OF WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
IF THE BAY WERE ALL OF A SUDDEN
TWO FEET HIGHER.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S AN
AWFUL LOT OF BLUE AN AWFUL LOT
OF GREEN AROUND THE BAY WHICH IS
NOW DRY.
AND THIS IS ON A PRETTY
SUNNY BEAUTIFUL WINDLESS DAY
WITHOUT A HIGH TIDE THAT IS A
KING TIED.
AND THE KEY HERE IS THAT SCORES
OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES
AND BUSINESSES AND PLACES OF
WORSHIP IN HOSPITALS AND
SCHOOLS.
ARE GOING TO BE HIT BY FLOODS.
AND FLOODING IS NOT SIMPLY A
NUISANCE.
FLOODING HAS TREMENDOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPLICATIONS IT HAS
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
DISLOCATION IMPLICATIONS.
SO WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
NINE COUNTIES IN FORTY ONE
CITIES
LED BY BC DC BECOME MORE
RESILIENT SO THAT THEIR PEOPLE
WHO LIVE THERE BECOME MORE
RECENTLY.
AND TO PUT AN EVEN FINER POINT
ON IT.
WHILE MANY PEOPLE LOOK AT SAN
FRANCISCO BAY NOW AND ADMIRE HOW
BEAUTIFUL IT IS WHEN BC DC WAS
CREATED THE BAY WAS NOT
EVERYBODY'S FRONT YARD. HE WAS
EVERYBODY'S BACKYARD PEOPLE
DUMPED IN THE BAY.
THERE IT THERE ARE ARE JUST AND
LARGE NUMBER OF DUMPS THAT HAVE
NOW BEEN CAPPED WHICH MEANS THAT
IS FLAT MORE AND MORE FLOODING
OCCURS SLOWLY MORE AND MORE
HEALTH RISKS.
SO WATER BE CDCS TASKS WELL
WE'RE HERE TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS REDUCE THAT RISK OF
FLOODING THROUGH BOTH PLANNING
AND REGULATORY FUNCTIONS
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BAY AND
WE UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE.
SO THERE THREE ON THE GROUND
WAYS IN WHICH BE CDC IS HELPING
THE FOLKS IN THE BAY AREA.
THE FIRST THIS THROUGH PLANNING
ARE ADAPTING TO RISING TIDES
PROGRAM WHICH IS A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED PROGRAM OF PLANNING
WHICH PUTS PEOPLE FIRST.
NOT HIGHWAYS.
NOT WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
BUT ACTUALLY PEOPLE AND WE WORK
WITHIN NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT THEY HAVE
STRATEGIES AVAILABLE TO THEM TO
REDUCE THEIR RISK OF FLOODING.
AND THAT IS ACTUALLY HELPED FUND
BY CALTRANS AND THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
BECAUSE CALTRANS RECOGNIZES THAT
IT'S HIGHWAYS AS LONG WITH
BART'S IN ALL THE OTHER
TRANSPORTATION NETWORKS AND THE
PRIORITY DEVELOPMENT AREAS IN
THE COMMUNITIES AT RISK.
MANY OF WHICH ARE LOW INCOME
MANY OF WHICH ARE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR NEED THE ASSISTANCE.
SO THERE ARE TWO EXAMPLES IF YOU
LOOK AT THE SECOND PAGE YOU'LL
SEE A BRIDGE THAT LOOKS PRETTY
OLD.
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE BRIDGE RIGHT
BEHIND EIGHTEEN T. BALLPARK
THAT'S THE LEFTY O. DUAL BRIDGE
WHICH IS YOU CAN SEE ON.
A BASIC NICE DAY IS NOT THAT FAR
ABOVE WHERE THE WATER HITS.
SO IMAGINE WHAT HAPPENS IN
TWENTY FIFTY WITH YOU HAVE TO
FOUR FEET OF RISING SEA LEVEL
PLUS A STORM. PLUS A KING TIED
WHICH IS GOING TO RAISE WHICH IS
GOING TO RAISE THE HIGH TIDE EN
EL NINO WHICH CAN RAISE THE
ELEVATION OF THE BAY BY AS MUCH
AS TWO FEET.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE NEXT PICTURE
THAT'S HAYWARD RIGHT NEXT TO THE
DUMBARTON BRIDGE APPROACH ON THE
BEAUTIFUL GORGEOUS CLEAR BLUE
SKY DAY AND IT'S FLOODED.
THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
AND IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
NEXT FOUR SLIDES WHICH ARE
ACTUALLY PUT TOGETHER. THAT'S
HOW THIS IS AN EXAMPLE IN WILL
MOURN HAPPY TO TALK TO STAFF IN
YOU AND WHOEVER ABOUT IT. ABOUT
HOW HE WOULD RESIDENTS USING BC
DC IN OUR APPROACH WERE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT FOR DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES TO MAKE HAY WORD
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES.
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS FAR MORE
RESILIENT EVEN IN THE FACE OF
THE SLIDE YOU JUST SAW.
SO IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
NEXT SLIDE IT'S SIMPLY A
DESCRIPTION OF THE ART BAY AREA
PROJECT WITH CALTRANS THE MTC
THE FIRST EVER VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENT OF THE BAY AREA WITH
REGARD TO ACTUAL RISING SEA.
AND IT'S IT WILL HAVE THAT
COMPLETED NEXT JUNE AND THAT
WILL BECOME THE BASIS OF THE
NEXUS STABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY
AS WELL. TO ENSURE THAT THAT
THEN GETS PUT INTO THE
INTO THE STRATEGY HOW DO WE
BECOME MORE RESILIENT.
THE SECOND WAY WE HELP IS TO
PERMITTING.
WE ACTUALLY PERMIT NEW
STRUCTURES.
THE CDC ISN'T AFRAID TO PERMIT
NEW STRUCTURES BECAUSE WE WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
RESILIENT TO SEA LEVEL RISE.
AND WE MAKE SURE. THAT WE BUT
PROVE BOTH HARDSCAPE WHICH WE
ALL KNOW IS SAY BUILDINGS AND
THE LIKE AND WALLS. BUT JUST AS
IMPORTANT MARSHLAND ENTRY AND
WETLANDS
BECAUSE THOSE PROVIDE A SPONGE
AFFECT
ESPECIALLY IN THE SHALLOWER
AREAS WHICH CAN REDUCE FLOODING
AND ALSO CREATE HABITAT.
AND MOST IMPORTANT WE'RE
LEARNING WITH THE PERMIT
APPLICANTS HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN ADAPT TO THOSE CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE CAN SAY TO FEET BY TWENTY
FIFTY BUT WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
GOING TO BE TWO FEET BY TWENTY
FIFTH YEAR FOUR FEET BY TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. IT COULD BE MORE IT
COULD BE LESS WHICH MEANS THAT
WE REQUIRED THOSE PERMIT
APPLICANTS TO HAVE AN ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PLAN. SO THAT THEY
CAN QUICKLY ADAPT
A CHANGING CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND EVEN MORE IMPORTANT WERE
WORKING WITH.
THE PUBLIC TO ACTUALLY LOOK
INTERNAL TO BE CDC AND CHANGE
OUR OWN POLICIES AND DO IT
TRANSPARENTLY WITH WORKSHOPS AND
WITH PUBLIC INPUT.
TO THE WAY TO IN THE TO THE
ISSUES WE'RE DEALING WITH ARE
THE NEXT TWO PAGES.
THE FIRST IS PHIL BC DC WAS
CREATED TO REDUCE THE FILL IN
THE BAY MAKE THE BAY BIGGER.
BUT IF WE WANT TO IF WE WANT TO
BOLSTER CREATE AND PROTECT
WETLANDS.
WE HAVE TO PUT.
IN THE BANG WE HAVE TO CREATE
THE WETLANDS SO HOW DO WE CHANGE
OUR HOW DO WE CHANGE OUR PROCESS
IN THE WAY WE LOOK AT DIRT. AND
DIRT IN THE BAY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY EXPAND THE
WETLANDS TO VERY TECHNICAL ISSUE
BELIEVE IT OR NOT AND WE'RE
DOING A PRETTY WELL WILL HAVE
THAT DISCUSSED AND AND DEBATED
IN DONE WITHIN.
.
EIGHT EIGHT TO NINE MONTHS.
SECOND WERE ALSO LOOKING COURSE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND SOCIAL
EQUITY
BECAUSE AS I SAID SO MUCH OF THE
BAYS SHORELINE WHICH HAVE
RESIDENTS ON IT ARE IN PLACES
LIKE THE CANAL DISTRICT IN
SANDRA FELL. BAYVIEW HUNTERS
POINT SAN FRAN.
EAST PALO ALTO AL WEISEL.
WEST OAKLAND AND GOING UP TO
RICHMOND.
VERY VERY DIFFICULT PLACES IN
WHICH PEOPLE LIVE AND LIVE WITH
FAMILIES AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE AREAS ARE NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. JUST LIKE
THEY WERE IN MANY WERE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AREAS AND TIMES IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
SOLUTION FOR THE BAY WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY NOT JUST SOME PEOPLE.
AND THEN FINALLY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT WHAT WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IS TO
CHANGE NEAR TERM AND THIS IS
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE
WE'RE SMALL STATE AGENCY WHERE
FORTY PEOPLE BUDGETS LESS THAN
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS I WAS JUST
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
MORNING WORKING WITH THEM. AND
THEY UNDERSTAND THESE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES SO I THINK YOU'LL SEE
SOME DIFFERENCES WITH REGARD TO
HOW BE CDC WORKS.
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THAT
HOWEVER WHERE THE GTR A FUNDS
THAT YOU ALL SUPPLIED FOR
ADAPTATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
THIS PAST YEAR.
WERE THE RECIPIENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A LOT OF THE
STATE BUDGET BUT IT'S A LOT TO
BE CDC. AND ENABLES US TO WORK
EVEN MORE CLOSELY WITH THOSE
KINDS OF NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND OF COURSE THOSE FUNDS ALSO
WANTS THE COASTAL COMMISSION IN
THE COSTA CONSERVANCY WHICH MAKE
GRANTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO
THEY CAN ACTUALLY DO WORK ON
THEIR OWN.
AND WORK WITH US.
SO WHAT'S TO KEEP MOST UPPERMOST
IN MINE. WE NEED TO HAVE
SOLUTIONS THAT PROTECT WHOLE
COMMUNITIES FROM FLOODING. AND
FROM INUNDATION BECAUSE IT'S
ONLY GOING TO GET MORE AND MORE
COMMON WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS CAN KEEP
HOLE IN THE NEAR TERM.
YOU CAN'T HAVE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC DISLOCATION BECAUSE
THAT DISRUPTS EVERYTHING.
AND AS SANDY KIND OF STORM WHICH
WE HAVEN'T HAD YET
COULD CAUSE UP TO SAY TEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
DAMAGE TO THE BAY AREA ACCORDING
TO THE BAY AREA COUNCIL.
AND SO WE NEED TO BE PREPARED
FOR THAT TYPE OF OCCURRENCE
FLOODING HAPPENS NOW SO LETS
TAKE A LOOK AT THE LAST THREE
SLIDES AND I'LL SHOW YOU.
THE FIRST IS AND YOU CAN SEE IT
RIGHT BEHIND YOU. THE SAN
FRANCISCO EMBARCADERO. THAT'S
THE BAY BRIDGE RIGHT BEHIND THAT
TO THE KING TIED. THAT HAPPENS
TWICE A YEAR NOW.
ON A CLEAR DAY NOT ON A STORMY
DAY.
THE NEXT PICTURE
SOUTHERN MARIN. THAT'S HIGHWAY
ONE OH ONE ABOVE THAT WHERE YOU
SEE THE BUS.
RIGHT BELOW IT IS THE ON RAMP AN
OFF RAMP MONEY. TIED BEAUTIFUL
DAY IN DECEMBER OR JANUARY
THE FLOODING OCCURS ALREADY.
AND THEN FINALLY THE NEXT YOU
PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT THE
FLOODING OF STATE HIGHWAY THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH CONNECTS FOR
COUNTIES IN NORTH BAY AREA. THIS
IS AN INTERSECTION JUST AFTER
THAT FLOODING.
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW WE CAN
DISRUPT GOODS AND JUST AS
IMPORTANT PEOPLE MOVEMENT.
SO THAT WAS OF THE KIND OF
ISSUES THAT WERE DEALING WITH
AND WE'RE SOLVING WITH OUR
PARTNERS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
TO ALL THREE OF YOU THERE. I
THINK HAS BEEN A PRESENTATION
THAT.
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AS A STATE AGENCY.
WHAT IS BEING DONE AND REGION
AND THEN OF COURSE THE EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES I? GUESS MY QUESTION
WOULD BE.
IF WE COULD BEGIN TO MAYBE FILL
IN SOME GAPS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT ARE AREAS
RIGHT THAT WE CAN BEGIN TO LOOK
AT.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
THAT ALLOW US TO BEGIN TO FILL
IN THOSE GAPS KEEPING IN MIND
WITH.
I THINK ALL OF YOU HAVE TOUCHED
ON. THESE UP COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
BY CLAIMING THAT CHANGE AND SO
WE CAN GO DOWN.
THE PANELIST AS HE PRESENTED TO
JUST KIND OF REYES PROFOUND SOME
OF THESE AREAS THAT WE CAN BEGIN
TO. FILL IN GAPS ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE ADDITIONAL NEEDS.
.
OOPS.
IS THAT JUST TO MAKE SURE I HAVE
THE QUESTION RIGHT.
IS HERE ARE YOU WANTS TO KNOW
KIND OF FROM A STATE LEVEL HOW
YOU CAN CONNECT.
.
WATER ISSUES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
OR BETWEEN ALL THE DIFFERENCE I
THINK BETWEEN BETWEEN THE KIND
OF DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT RIGHT.
THAT ULTIMATELY LEAD BACK TO THE
POPULATIONS THAT YOU'RE FOCUSED
ON.
WHETHER BE IN THE EASTERN
PECHELL VALUE OR CENTRAL VALLEY.
I THINK.
AS I MENTIONED. I'VE. AT LEAST
REGARDING WATER SUPPLY ACROSS
THE STATE I DO THINK THAT.
OUR PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE THAT.
I ENTIRE STATE COOPERATIVE
EFFORT TO ADDRESS WATER SUPPLY
IS REALLY NECESSARY AND THAT
SPANS ALL THE SOLUTIONS THAT I
SPOKE ABOUT. FROM LOCAL GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT TO ENSURING
THAT THERE'S A STATE FUND FOR
INSURING FOR.
ESTABLISHING A RELIABLE DRINKING
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND
THEN LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
PLANNING THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
CLIMATE CHANGE WATER SUPPLY
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE
AT LOW INCOME AND. COMMITTEES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
SO WE KNOW THERE'S A AN EFFORT
UNDER WAY. A CONVERSATION THAT
THERE'S ALSO MADE IT TO. AND
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND AND NOW INCORPORATED INTO A
BUDGET.
CONVERSATION ABOUT THEY FUND
RIGHT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
AREAS THAT MANY OF SAID THAT
THAT.
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS ALPHA THESE
REGIONS THAT.
FUNDS ONLY ONLY TOUCHES JUST A
TINY BIT BUT WE KNOW THAT IT
WOULD BE ON A RECURRING BASIS.
THAT THAT FUND COULD
POTENTIALLY BE AVAILABLE. I
GUESS SOME WHAT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING AS.
YOU KNOW BUT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL I COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
DURING MY TENURE THERE TO UPDATE
THE GENERAL PLAN.
AND INCORPORATE YOU KNOW PUBLIC
HEALTH ELEMENTS.
TO THE GENERAL PLAN WE'RE NOW
TALKING ABOUT ASKING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO
INCORPORATE CLIMATE CHANGE.
ADAPTATION PLANS. THERE'S A
CONVERSATION OF INTEGRATING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
ELEMENTS TO THE PLAN I MEAN
WHAT DO YOU SEE.
THOSE EFFORTS. ULTIMATELY
PRODUCING AND WHETHER OR NOT AT
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL ONE
THING AS SAYING HERE WE HAVE
THIS PLAN THAT'S IN CORPORATE
JOB PLAN.
THE OTHER IS ACTUALLY AT BEING
CARRIED OUT. IN NO.
COLLECTIVELY BY OUR LOCAL
LEADERS AND DO YOU SEE BABY. AS
A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LOS
ANGELES.
AREA.
CHALLENGES OPPORTUNITIES
I COME THAT IF YOU CAN COMMENT
JUST ADD TO THAT.
CONVERSATION ABSOLUTELY AT TO
KIND OF ADDRESS THAT THE GAPS
AND THEN AND THAT'S.
I'M ISSUE I THINK.
I. THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE SO
MUCH SOME POTENTIAL FOR HOW THEY
CAN.
ENGAGE AND THAT ARE REALLY
LIMITED AT THE MOMENT IN TERMS
OF OF STAFF AND RESOURCES.
AND AND SO THAT'S KIND OF ONE
OF THE BIG GAPS AND IT IT MEANS
THAT LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF THE
BANDWIDTH TO BE INVOLVED IN ALL
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
PARTNERS.
AND AND THEN SAID.
.
TO ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
KIND OF DOING A BETTER JOB OF
ENGAGING.
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT IT WOULD
ACTUALLY LOOK LIE TO IMPLEMENT
ON SOME OF THESE PLANS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITIES.
HAVING NOT HAVING.
KIND OF AT THE MOMENT.
LOCAL A LOT OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS DON'T HAVE THAT'S
THE STAFF CAPACITY AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE.
TO TO KIND OF DO THAT SO AT
WITH MORE CAPACITY YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE INVOLVED IN MORE OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS. BUT
pALSO TO REALLY DO MEANINGFUL
LIKE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
PARTNER WITH COMMUNITIES ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES TRAINING
THIS IS SO CRITICAL TO SEE THOSE
PLANS I'M KIND OF.
CARRIED OUT.
THANK YOU PROJECT ADD FOR IT BUT
I THINK WE'RE ALL SORT OF SAYING
THE SAME THING FROM SORT OF TEN
DEGREES OFF BECAUSE WE ALL WORK
WITH LOCAL. PLANNERS AND WE ALL
WORK WITH LOCAL.
COMMUNITY GROUPS WELL LOOK WORK
WITH LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
BECAUSE CANDIDLY AND YOU COME
FROM THAT WORLD THAT'S WHERE THE
RUBBER HITS THE ROAD. AND I
THINK THAT IN MANY RESPECTS WHAT
THE CDC DOES AS A STATE AGENCY
CAN BE A MODEL. AND HOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY CAN BE A
MODEL BECAUSE HERE YOU HAVE NINE
COUNTIES AND FORTY ONE CITIES.
AND THEY COULD EACH HAVE THEIR
OWN POLICIES.
IN IT AND THEY DO. AND WHAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE IS THAT A.
AND IS IS A FLOODING POLICY A
RESILIENCE POLICY FOR ONE COUNTY
DOESN'T ADVERSELY AFFECT ANOTHER
COUNTY BY CAUSING MORE FLOODING
OVER ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BAY FOR EXAMPLE.
SO WHAT WE AND SO THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE IN IN IN IN OUR SET UP.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL THE
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES AND WE
WORK ON A CONSENSUS BASIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK AT THE
BAY AS A WHOLE. AND AS WE PLAN
WE BRING IN THOSE LOCAL PLANNERS
AND TEACH THOSE LOCAL PLANNERS
HOW TO THINK ABOUT NOT ONLY
THEIR WORK UT HOW THEIR WORK
AFFECTS THE FOLKS NEXT DOOR.
AND AS WE PERMIT WE WORK WITH
THE PRIVATE DEVELOPER SIDE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHAT THEY DO ALSO
ENSURE SOME LEVEL A PAVE VERY
LARGE REVOLUTE A LEVEL OF
RESILIENCE AS WELL.
SO IT COMES DOWN TO ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH PEOPLE IN A WAY
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY HAVE A POSITIVE ROLE
TO PLAY AND THE SHOULDN'T BE
SCARED ABOUT. THE HEAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE SCARED ABOUT THE
WATER AS MUCH AS THEY SHOULD
FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN ALL FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ACTUALLY MAKE IT
BETTER. AND ALL THAT SOUNDS A
LITTLE POLLYANNA ASH BUT FROM A
PLANNERS PERSPECTIVE AND I'M NOT
A PLANNER BUT FROM A PLANNERS
PERSPECTIVE. THAT'S HOW YOU GET
SOME KIND OF POSITIVE CHANGE.
THANK YOU I THINK I'M YOU CAN
SHED LIGHT TO I THINK THE
IMPORTANCE OF.
AND THE ROLE THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCIES PLAY.
AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE CLOSING.
COMMENT ABOUT PLANNING I THINK
MUCH OF IT. REALLY BOILS DOWN
TO.
YOU KNOW THE PLANNING.
OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN THERE ARE
SOME.
LOCATIONS THAT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I CAN SPEAK FOR THE REGION
THAT I REPRESENT THAT IS
PROJECTED TO CONTINUE. TO SEE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
IN THOSE AREAS AND YOU HAVE
THESE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES RIGHT
TO IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES.
AND GET AHEAD OF MUCH OF WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS CAUSING
SOME CHALLENGES IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU SHEDDING
LIGHT ON THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
JUST MAYBE CLOSE. AND THIS
PANEL BY ADDING YOU KNOW WHAT IT
IS THAT THAT US HERE AT THE
STATE POLICY LEVEL.
ASIDE FROM THE NEED FOR.
BUILDING GREATER CAPACITY IN.
OF COURSE THE INVESTMENT INTO
WELL I'M.
AND THE RESOURCES NEEDED ARE
THERE SOME POLICIES THAT THAT
YOU THINK.
THE STATE COULD ADAPT.
OR ADOPT AND.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR LOCAL
AND REGIONAL PARTNERS.
TO HELP CARRY OUT SOME OF THESE
OBJECTIVES.
SURE I'LL GO FIRST.
.
OF A SO I.
AND.
TO KIND OF ADD ON TO THE LAST
COMMENTS ABOUT LOCAL PLANNING I
THINK.
YOU NO TAXES THAT IN ADDITION TO
MORE FUNDING FOR RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WATER SUPPLY
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND MORE EFFECTIVE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT.
JUST WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE.
PLANNING FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
WILL WITHSTAND KLEIN CLIMATE
IMPACTS.
AS OF NOW THEY'RE THE MOST
VULNERABLE UNTIL TERMS OF HEALTH
BACK IMPACTS FROM PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING BUT IF YOU ADD ON TO
THAT OUR FUTURE ROOF CLIMATE.
VARIABILITY THAT'S GOING TO BE
EVEN.
MORE EGREGIOUSLY IMPACTING AND
EQUITABLY IMPACTING THIS THAT
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE STATE
TO WORK ALONGSIDE AT.
WORK ALONGSIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO.
FURTHER DEVELOP THE POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN SET OUT AND SP
TWO FORTY FOUR SP ONE THOUSAND.
WHERE?
GENERAL PLANS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLANNING DOES NEED TO
TAKE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS INTO ACCOUNT.
AND PLAN FOR ALLEN HOW IT WILL
GET EFFECTIVE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHAT
WATER WASTE WATERS.
STORM WATER PROTECTION FIRE
PROTECTION.
AND AND FURTHER.
FURTHER DEVELOP THAT AS FAR
INSOFAR AS IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
CLIMATE THAT ADAPTATION.
THANK YOU.
I THINK I'M AS AS WE WORK AND I
WOULD ECHO AMANDA SUGGESTIONS
AROUND KIND OF.
INCREASING CAPACITY AROUND.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND.
AND I THINK THAT KIND OF
PROVIDE A CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THROUGH.
THROUGH KIND OF POLICY SETTING
THAT HELPS US.
KIND OF HAVE STANDARDS SO FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN WE'RE WORKING ON
URBAN HEAT ISLAND REDUCTION.
YOU KNOW HAD THINKING THROUGH
COOL PAVEMENTS HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE BECAUSE THERE ISN'T IT
STATEWIDE STANDARD FOR FOR COOL
PAVEMENTS FOR EXAMPLE.
SO THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WHERE.
THAT THE STATE CAN GET GET OUT
AHEAD OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND.
AND HELP.
PROVIDE PROVIDE US KIND OF
STANDARDS THAT THAT WE CAN ADOPT
HAS ALWAYS REALLY HELPFUL IN
THAT AREA AS WELL.
EXAMPLE THANK YOU.
THE LAST THING I'M GONNA DO IS
TO SAY THAT NOBODY NEEDS MORE
RESOURCES.
BECAUSE WE EVERYBODY DOES.
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO STEAL
ASSISTANT SECRETARY BRIGHTS
THUNDER WHO COMES UP RIGHT AFTER
ME ABOUT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY BUT I THINK THE RESOURCE
AGENCY HAS A REALLY GOOD IDEA
ABOUT HOW. ON THE FLOODING IN
RESILIENCE SIDE WE CAN WORK.
WHICH IS TO ISSUE GUIDANCE THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN USE TO
HELP THEMSELVES FIGURE OUT HOW
TO HOW TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
MORE RESILIENCE AND TO CREATE
WORKSHOPS AND TO. BE DOWN THERE
WITH THOSE LOCAL PLANNERS AND
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT HOW ALL OF
THAT WORKS.
BECAUSE THE MORE THEY ACTUALLY
SEE ON THE LOCAL LEVEL I THINK
THAT THE STATE ACTUALLY HAS THE
ABILITY TO HELP FROM A PLANNING
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THE BETTER
OFF WE ARE.
AND I THINK THAT THE RESOURCES
AGENCY IS AS IS IS DOING A
PRETTY DARN GOOD JOB OF THAT. I
WOULD I WOULD END BY SAYING THAT
I AM OF THE GENERATION. WHICH
REMEMBERS.
THE FRAM OIL FILTER COMPANY
WHICH PROBABLY NOBODY ELSE DOES
BUT IF YOU DON'T PAY ATTENTION
TO YOUR OIL FILTER.
YOUR YOUR ENGINE BLOWS UP RIGHT.
THEY USED TO HAVE A MARVELOUS
COMMERCIAL THAT ALWAYS ENDED
WITH THE SAYING.
YOU CAN PAY ME NOW.
OR YOU CAN PAY ME LATER.
AND THE KEY THERE IS SPEND LESS
MONEY NOW ON PREVENTION IN ORDER
TO AVOID SPENDING MORE MONEY
LATER ON CLEANING IT UP.
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD MAN.
ANALOGY OR STATEMENT TO MAKE A.
THAT IS OPERABLE TO A LOT OF
WHAT WE DO.
AND GOVERNMENT AND EVEN IN OUR
OWN. PERSONAL.
FINANCIAL ENDEAVORS THAT
WHETHER IT'S A TAKING CARE OF
OUR OWN HOME.
ALRIGHT IF YOU DON'T TAKE CARE
OF THE ROOF.
THE OTHER THINGS KIND OF
FOLLOWING THINK THE GOVERNOR DID
A GOOD JOB IN USING THOSE TYPES
OF.
COMPARISONS WHEN HE WAS PUSHING
HIS AGENDA I AS A RELEASE
INVESTING IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND I THINK IT'S APPLICABLE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL SO THANK YOU. TO
ALL THREE OF YOU.
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS WE
APPRECIATE. THE INDULGENCE AND
DALMA CALL UP THE NEXT THREE
SPEAKERS THANK YOU YOU.
KALEY BRIGHTWOOD
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
LOIS BED'S WORTH WITH
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PAIN RESURGENT
KAREN SMITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS SIZE A PRESENTATION ON
STATE EFFORTS TO GUIDE.
THE ADAPTATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO LET'S START WITH THE
UNDERSECRETARY GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU I. THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND.
STAFF WE.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU HAVING
THIS HEARING AND INVITING US TO
TESTIFY.
IN.
TO JUST INTRODUCE MYSELF MY
NAME IS CALEY BRIGHT AND THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR CLIMATE AND
ENERGY AT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND.
I MANAGE THAT CAN A PORTFOLIO
OF MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION
PROGRAMS UNDERNEATH THE AGENCY.
SO JUMPING.
A LITTLE BIT TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE POSED THAT TO LARRY.
FROM THE CDC AT THE END OF HIS
TESTIMONY.
I JUST WANTED OPEN UP BY SAYING
PLANNING IS ESSENTIAL PLANNING
IS GREAT.
LOCALS NEED A LOTTA HELP
PLANNING.
BUT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
OTHER STATE PROGRAMS ARE
PLANNING IS ESSENTIAL AND THAT'S
GREAT NOT ALL LOCALS AND NOT ALL
GOVERNMENTS ENGAGE VOLUNTARILY
ENGAGING. IN PLANNING AFFRONT
AND SOMETIMES YOU NEED TO. DRAG
THEM ALONG. IT SOMETIMES LOCALS
ENGAGE IN PLANNING AND DO THE
RIGHT PLANS BUT THEY DON'T
FOLLOW THE PLANS AND SOMETIMES
ME LEVERAGE TO MAKE SURE THEY DO
WHAT THEY SAY THEY WANT TO DO.
.
WE HAVE AT THIS MOMENT MORE
RESOURCES IN OUR STATE BUDGET
AND MORE RESOURCES ON THE BALLOT
TO BE INCLUDED INTO THE STATE
BUDGET. TIAS LEVERAGE TO FOR
TO.
INCENTIVIZE.
ALL OF. THE ACTORS TO DO THE
RIGHT THINGS WITH REGARDS TO
CLIMATE CHANGE GOING FORWARD AND
IN THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE
MISTER CHAIR AND WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
REALLY A SET US UP IN A BETTER
POSITION THAN WE'VE EVER BEEN
AND.
TO TAKE THIS WORK ON SO. YOU
SHOULD FEEL LIKE YOUR YOUR. YOUR
WORK IS STARTING FROM A FROM A
VERY SOUND AND HEALTHY FISCAL
PLACE BUT WE ALSO HAVE.
.
ALL OF THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED IN
THE POLICY TOOL BOXES WELL MAYBE
NOT BUT. YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A VERY GREAT WARD
JUST A POLICY TOOLS TO TO WORK
ON THESE ISSUES. AND.
YOU KNOW A LOT TO MOVE FORWARD
ON SO TODAY YOU KNOW I WAS GONNA
TALK I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THE.
STATES ACTIONS AROUND CLIMATE
CHANGE FOR STATE PROGRAMS.
.
IN HOW WE CAN MOBILIZE THE
EFFORTS OF ALL OF ARE STATE
PROGRAMS TOWARDS MEETING THESE
GOALS THAT TRANSIT ACROSS ALL
THE DIFFERENT POLICY AREAS.
THE SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA.
PLAN IS ESSENTIALLY THE
BLUEPRINT FOR HOW THE STATE
PLANS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
IT IS A CATALOG OF THE ACTIONS
THAT WERE DOING AT THE STATE.
BUT ALSO A AND THAT KNOWLEDGE
ONE OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO DO
SO YOU ASKED THE QUESTION OF
WHAT ARE THE GAPS.
THE BOOK THAT WE TODAY HEDGES
SENSUALLY AS A BOOK OF IT SHOULD
BE YOUR CHEAT SHEET FOR THESE OF
THE GAPS THAT THE PROGRAM
MANAGERS AND EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR STATE. HAVE
IDENTIFIED AS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE YOU
KNOW SPAN A BROAD SPECTRUM OF OF
OF COST AND SIZE AND AND.
DETAIL BUT THEY REALLY ARE
MEANT TO GIVE THE POLICY THAT
THAT'S IT'S QUITE IT'S QUITE A
THREE DOCUMENT. THE REALLY MEANT
TO GIVE YOU THE POLICY MAKERS
AND.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BRANCH AND IN
FUTURE.
FUTURE LEADERS JUST THIS THIS
CLEAR CLEAN BLUEPRINT FOR WHAT
TO DO AND WHERE TO ACT ON.
.
THE SCOPE OF THE PLAN IS
DELIBERATELY CONSTRAINED AROUND
STATE. GOVERNMENT AND ITS
FUNCTIONS IN THE PAST THE PLAN
HAS.
WOVEN IN CLIMATE IMPACTS AND
MORE CALLS TO ACTION BUT WE WERE
VERY DELIBERATE AND AND AND AND
DESIGNING THE PLAN AROUND. JUST
THOSE SPECIFIC STEPS THAT WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT AS NECESSARY
AND WE THOUGHT IT MADE A VERY
MUCH CLEANER.
PRESENTATION AND GAVE
POLICYMAKERS MORE TO ACT ON.
THE.
.
SO WE ORGANIZED A PLAN.
MUCH LIKE THE POLICY COMMITTEES
IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEES
ORGANIZED IN THE STATE.
AND WE DID THAT BECAUSE YOU YOU
NEED WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE YOU NEED TO THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF IT IS NOT JUST
ONE COMMITTEE. IT IS NOTS ONE
DEPARTMENT ITS SUB THAT YOU KNOW
IT IS SOMETHING THAT REALLY
IMPACTS.
EVERY AGENCY STATE GOVERNMENT
AND EVERY PROGRAM SHOULD BE
TUNING THEIR BASS LINES TO
ADDRESS THESE.
IMPACTS LIKE.
HEAT ISLAND FACT SEA LEVEL RISE
AT CETERA.
.
WE HAVE ELEVEN DIFFERENT
CHAPTERS IN THE PLAN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT ENERGY LAND USE
PUBLIC HEALTH TRANSPORTATION
AGRICULTURE BIODIVERSITY
FOREST'S.
OCEAN COAST.
WATER AND PARKS AND RECREATION
IN CALIFORNIA CULTURE.
.
IT'S ORGANIZED WITH ONE HIGH
LEVEL RECOMMENDATION AT THE TOP
OF EACH CHAPTER AND THEN CAPTAIN
RECOMMENDATIONS UNDERNEATH THAT
THAT SPELL OUT HOW TO GET TO THE
HIGHER LEVEL RECOMMENDATION.
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THAT I'VE PULLED OUT JUST TO
GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT BUT YOU
CAN READ THROUGH THE PLAN LATER.
ONE THAT TRANSLATES ACROSS MOST
OF THE CHAPTERS IN IS
INCORPORATE CLIMATE
CONSIDERATIONS INTO PLANNING AT
ALL LEVELS THIS WAS COVERED BY
THE LAST PANEL. PRETTY IN DEPTH
BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS IS
ESPECIALLY.
IMPORTANT FOR AGENCIES LIKE
CALTRANS TO WHO HAVE INCREDIBLE
MANDATES TO DEVELOP
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH NEW FUNDING
IN THE NEXT COMING YEARS.
CALTRAIN SHOULD BE.
YOU KNOW SET UP AS A AS A REAL
GOOD MODEL OF WHAT WHAT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO THEY HAVE
RECENTLY ENGAGED IN.
.
VULNERABILITY REPORTS FOR THEIR
ENTIRE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AND THEN ONCE THOSE REPORTS ARE
DONE IT'LL BE VERY FASCINATING
AND SOMETIMES POLITICAL TO SEE
HOW THOSE REPORTS TRANSLATE TO
THE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
PROCESS THAT IS CONTROLLED BY
MANY DIFFERENT SIDES AS IT GOES
DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE'LL BE WATCHING HOW THOSE
PLANS DEVELOP AND THEY WILL ALSO
BE WATCHING HOW THOSE THOSE.
FUNDING DECISIONS ARE MADE DOWN
TO THE GROUND. AND WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT. WHO CAN JUMP
THROUGH SOME OF THESE?
?
INCREASING WATER CONSERVATION
AGRICULTURE NOT ONLY THROUGH.
NOT ONLY THROUGH THE IRRIGATION
SYSTEMS BUT ALSO THROUGH
INCREASING THE SLOW CONTENT OF
THE.
OF OF OF THE SOIL ITSELF TO THE
OF THE THE CARBON CONTENT OF THE
SOIL ITSELF. I'M THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT JUST NOT ONLY AS A
MITIGATION SOLUTION BUT ALSO AS
AND.
AS A PRODUCTIVITY SOLUTION FOR.
FOOD PRODUCTION AND.
IT IS REALLY EMERGING IN THE IN
THE CLIMATE SOLUTIONS SPACE AS
ONE OF THE KEY OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE TO EXPAND THE USE OF OUR.
WORKING LANDS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND INCREASE FOOD
SECURITY IN THE PROCESS.
ONE OF THE FINAL IN EXAMPLES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ACTUALLY CAME
FROM.
OUR OUR MEETINGS IN YOUR
DISTRICT WHEN WE MET WITH IN IN
THE IN COACHELLA WE WERE TALKING
TO HIM RESIDENTS ABOUT WHAT THEY
WANTED TO SEE IN THIS PLAN. AND
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
BEEN KIND OF TALKING ABOUT THE
BACKGROUND BUT REALLY JUST CAME
OUT FROM ALMOST EVERY ASIDE FROM
YOUR. FROM YOUR RESIDENCE WAS
THEY WANTED TO SEE HOW WE COULD
SAFEGUARD RECREATIONAL
RESOURCES.
AND ACCESS TO NATURAL RESOURCES
FOR THE PUBLIC IN LIGHT OF
CHANGING BOTH CHANGING IMPACTS
TO THOSE RESOURCES ON THE
BIODIVERSITY SIDE BUT ALSO
INCREASED HEAT. AND AN ABILITY
TO GO OUT IN THOSE HOT DAYS AND
TO ENJOY THEMSELVES.
.
AND YOU KNOW IT WAS REALLY
TELLING YOU KNOW THEY WERE JUST
THAT THAT.
THAT SECTION IN THE IMPORTANCE
OF THOSE RESIDENTS WAS
IT WAS REALLY TELLING THAT. YOU
KNOW THESE ARE THEY WANT TO SEE
GOVERNMENT RESPOND IN WAYS THAT
ARE IN OF COURSE MEANINGFUL AND
IMPACTFUL TO THEM IN THEIR DAILY
LIVES. ME THEY WANT THEIR ROADS
THEY WANT THEIR MAJOR
INTERSECTION BE PROTECTED.
WITHIN THE ALSO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW GO UP TO. THE
WHITEWATER PRESERVE AND AND GO
INTO THE DENOUNCED GO TO THE
COOL WATER WHEN IT'S A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DEGREES IN THE
VALLEY.
.
WE.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME WE PUT IN
A CHAPTER ON ACCESS TO PUBLIC
RECREATION HERE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH STATE PARKS.
THROUGH TO TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
YOU CREATE THOSE.
THOSE THOSE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES STATEWIDE EVEN IN
LIGHT OF THESE IMPACTS.
WHICH GET EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
WITH SEA LEVEL RISE CMAS FOR
COASTAL RESOURCES ARE VERY LOW
TO THE GROUND NEXT TO THE COAST
AND WE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
CAMPGROUNDS IT. MAY NOT BE
CAMPGROUNDS.
NEXT WE WE WORKED VERY HARD TO
INCORPORATE A CLIMATE JUSTICE
CHAPTER INTO THIS REPORT.
IT WAS.
TO TO TO BE HONEST IT WAS.
IT'S NOT EASY TO SO WE WORKED
PRESS THIRTY DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS IT'S NOT EASY TO
TAKE THIRTY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
INTO A CLIMATE JUSTICE
CONVERSATION. AND REALLY GET A
MEANINGFUL INTERACTION THAT IN
THE END RESULTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT REPRESENT
WHAT THOSE COMMUNITIES AND THOSE
NONPROFITS WRITER CALLING FOR.
WHEN.
WE DID THIS WE RECEIVED
TREMENDOUS HELP FROM THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY TO
SUPPORT PARTICIPANTS FROM
NONPROFIT GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND.
WE WENT TO A VERY.
INTENSIVE BACK AND FORTH
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY THOSE ACTUAL
HOW WE COULD TO THE EXISTING
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE PUBLIC
DRAFT BUT ALSO. BRING IN NEW
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REPRESENT ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT THAT.
THAT THAT ARE FACED
AND IN A IN THE AND WE FEEL VERY
PROUD OF.
OF THE CLIMATE EQUITY CHAPTER
THAT WE HAVE IN THE FRONT OF THE
OF THE DOCUMENT AND THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE TO SHOWCASE NOT
ONLY THAT. THESE ROOM YOU KNOW
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT ISSUES
BUT IT'S THE ONE PLACE IN THE
DOCUMENT YOU CAN SEE HOW
EVERYTHING FITS TOGETHER INTO
ONE COHESIVE PACKAGE IT'S NOT.
BROKEN INTO DIFFERENT POLICY
AREA SILOS SO.
FOR THIS FOR US THAT'S GOING TO
BE.
A REALLY IMPORTANT BLUEPRINT
FOR JUST ADDRESSING THE EQUITY
ISSUES ACROSS ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT WORK IN THE NEXT
VERSIONS OF MATURING THAT WORK.
WITH THE SAME NETWORKS BECAUSE
THAT WAS JUST INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE.
THE.
.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN
ITSELF IS IS IS IS IMPORTANT TO
TALK ABOUT EVEN THOUGH IT'S VERY
IT CAN BE IT'S MORE BEHIND THE
SCENES AND PROCESS ORIENTED.
WE.
SO AS I MENTIONED WE WORKED WITH
OVER THIRTY INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP THE PLAN.
WE WORKED FROM THE BOTTOM UP
FROM THE PROGRAM LEVEL UP TO THE
EXECUTIVE TO IDENTIFY THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING PROGRAM YOU
KNOW.
THOSE WHO THE PROGRAMS ARE IN
THE LATER STAGES OF THEIR
CAREERS AND HAVE BEEN DOING
THINGS THE SAME WAY FOR MANY.
FOR MANY YEARS AND AREN'T ALWAYS
AS WELCOME TO CHANGES WE WOULD
LIKE YOU KNOW WE WOULD ALL LIKE.
AND AND THE. THE STAFF THAT WERE
PUT IN CHARGE OF DRIVING THE.
PLAN AND AND I THINK THERE THINK
ON THE FIFTH PAGE OF THE PLAN.
YOU KNOW THEY REALLY REPRESENT A
NEW GENERATION OF STATE CIVIL
SERVANTS THAT ARE COMING INTO
THE WORKFORCE. AND THEY WERE
GIVEN THE VERY UNPLEASANT TASK
OF.
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR OF THE OF
THE OF THE PROGRAM MANAGER WHO
ME WHO'S FAIRLY SEND THEIR WAYS
AND TELLING THEM HE GOTTA YOU
GOTTA YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
CONSIDER CW X. Y. AND Z. AND.
CHANGE THE WAY WE'RE DOING AND
AND IT WAS IT WAS.
VERY PROMISING TO SEE THAT
WILLINGNESS BY THOSE PROGRAM
MANAGERS TAKE THE STEPS THAT
THEY RECOMMENDED. IT WAS
SURPRISING HOW LITTLE.
IN THE PAST I THINK THIS MORE
IT WAS MORE DIFFICULT BUT. THIS
TIME AROUND OF SIP IT WAS
ENCOURAGING HOW LITTLE WE HAD TO
PUSH THESE AGENCIES TO COME UP
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS SO.
WE FEEL WE YOU KNOW THAT
PROCESSES SOCIALIZING CLIMATE
CHANGE THROUGHOUT THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES IN THE END WE
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU DON'T NEED
AN AGENCY TO COORDINATE CLIMATE
CHANGE ACROSS DEPARTMENTS I MEAN
THAT WE SHOULD BE WORKING
OURSELVES OUT OF A. OUT OF A JOB
IN MANY WAYS HE'S JUST BE
BASELINE CONSIDERATIONS THE
PROGRAMS.
THINK ABOUT INCORPORATE INTO
THEIR INTO THEIR INTO THEIR
ACTIONS.
.
THE NEXT PIECE THAT I WANTED TO
JUST TOUCH ON IS THAT WE'VE WE
WERE WE WORKED REALLY HARD TO
DEVELOP. METRICS.
IN WAYS TO TRACK
PROGRESS ON THE DOCUMENT ITSELF.
WE WANT.
SAFEGUARDING TO TO BE A
TRANSPARENT.
ACCOUNTABILITY TOOL FOR FOR FOR
OUR FOR OURSELVES BUT ALSO FOR
EVERYBODY WATCHING GOVERNMENT I
MEAN IT SHOULD BE THE THING THAT
PEOPLE GRAB IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
TRANSPORTATION OR WHATNOT. YOU
SHOULD USE THAT AND THEN REALLY
PUSHED.
GOVERNMENT ON ARE YOU ACHIEVING
THESE GOALS THAT YOU SET OUT.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE KINDA EXPOSED
HERSELF IN MANY WAYS THERE BY
PUTTING THAT OUT THERE BUT IT'S
IT IT WAS INTENTIONAL BECAUSE WE
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE SO
WE CAN BE PUSHED HARDER. AND AND
MAKE THIS PROGRESS.
WE WILL GO FORWARD AND PUT OUT
REPORTS
BY THE END OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND.
THEN LATER ON ON HOW FAR WE'VE
COME IN AND MEETING THESE GOALS
BUT.
NEED I THINK WITH THE METRICS
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH REALLY IS ONE
OF THOSE AREAS WHERE IT IS GOING
TO BE CRITICAL THAT WE TRACK.
TRACK THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON POPULATION BUT ALSO
THAT IN THAT CAN HELP US FIND TO
NO RESPONSE.
.
THE.
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO SAY
KIND OF WRAP THIS UP IS.
WE'RE SEEING AS SINCE WE
RELEASED AS PLANNED.
THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO DO BUT IT'S
ALSO THE SAME TYPE OF EXERCISE
THE LOCALS NEED TO DO AS WELL.
AND WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
INTERESTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IN
THE PRODUCT THAT WE'VE PUT
TOGETHER.
THEY THEY THEY'RE USING IT AS A
MODEL IN MANY CASE WORK WERE
WORKING WITH THEM. AND WE REALLY
HELP THAT THOUGH THEY'LL TAKE
WHAT WE DID IMPROVE UPON IT AND
SOAP AND RELIEF LEAPFROG THE
STATE SO WE CAN COME OUT. NEXT
TIME WE WRITE THIS PLAN AND AND
AND DO IT IN A YOU KNOW JUST
KEEP INFORMING EACH OTHER
BECAUSE THIS IS ALL. THIS IS A
BRAND NEW AND AND AND REALLY
FIRST OF ITS KIND WORK IN THE
COUNTRY AND AND AND.
THE CROSS COUNTRY SO WERE. WERE
OR WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR HELP
FOR TRYING TO PUT A MODEL OUT
THERE AND WE GLADLY ACCEPT
PEOPLE'S RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
TO DO DO IT BETTER THE NEXT
TIME.
I THINK WE ALL ARE IN A BETTER
PLACE IF WE DO.
.
FINAL FULL FINAL FINAL COMMENT
IS ALL OF THIS WORK ON WHAT WE
WILL DO WILL BE BACKED UP BY THE
SCIENCE OF WHAT WE SHOULD
EXPECT.
CLIMATE CHANGE THE SUMMER WE
WILL BE RELEASING THEM THE
CALIFORNIA OF THE FOURTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT.
BY THE STATE IN WHICH WILL
INCLUDE ABOUT FIFTY DIFFERENT.
REPORTS ON ACTUAL CLIMATE
IMPACTS FOR FOR FOR DIFFERENT
SECTORS IN OUR IN OUR STATE IN
DIFFERENT REGIONS. THOSE REPORTS
WILL GET DOWN TO THE FINE GRAIN
DETAIL OF HOW MANY. HOW MUCH?
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT FIRE
SEVERITY WILL BE WHAT.
HOW HOW FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL BE IMPACTED THAT CETERA AND
THEN THEY'LL WE WRAPPED INTO
REGIONALIZED REGIONAL REPORTS
AND TOPICAL REPORT SO? IN IN
EACH REGION YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET A REALLY CRYSTAL CLEAR
SNAPSHOT OF WHAT IS THAT IMPACT
GOING TO BE IN THAT REGION. AND
THEN THAT CAN THEN TRANSLATE
INTO THE SAFEGUARDING PLAN ON
HOW TO THOSE PROGRAMS CONNECT TO
THOSE IMPACTS.
AND.
SO WITH THAT WE I THINK ALL A
PAUSE AND AND AND AND LET MY
COLLEAGUES GO PORTER TAKE
QUESTIONS HOW DO YOU THINK YOU
WILL COME BACK TO KOREA
QUESTIONS I WAS INTERESTED IN
THE.
AND WE'LL GET TO DETAILS OF.
BUT THERE NAY AGENCY THAT DIDN'T
PARTICIPATE AND IF SO WAS IT
JUST.
NO INTERSECTION OF THE ISSUE BUT
WE CAN GO BACK TO THAT WILL WANT
AN ACCREDITATION.
AND THAT CAN THANK YOU FOR FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
LOUISE BED'S WORTH ON THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
AND I WILL PICK UP REALLY I AM
ON THE THE PLANNING ELEMENTS
AROUND ADAPTATION AND SOME OF
THE WORK WE'RE DOING AT OPR.
BOWS TO WORK ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES BUT REALLY TO SUPPORT
LOCAL AND REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
IN WORKING AROUND.
AND ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS.
INSULTS CERTAIN.
WITH TALKING ABOUT THE GENERAL
PLAN GUIDELINES POTATO CAME UP
EARLIER.
.
SO LAST YEAR PARA COMPLETED THE
FIRST COMPREHENSIVE UPDATES THE
GENERAL PLAN GUIDELINES IN OVER
A DECADE.
AND THAT BEGAN WITH I JUST THE
FACT THAT IT NEEDED THING THEY
NEEDED TO BE UPDATED BUT WITH
SEVERAL GOALS IN MIND ONE WAYS
TO INTEGRATE CLIMATE CHANGE
CONSIDERATIONS THROUGHOUT. THAT
DOCUMENT AND INTO THAT PROCESS
OVERALL.
ENDED IDEALLY MAKE IT EASIER
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO.
.
TO ALIGN THEIR GENERAL PLAN WITH
CLIMATE ACTION PLANS AND OTHER
CLIMATE ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE
UNDERTAKING.
WHILE WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
THAT UPDATE SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY NINE.
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW WHICH
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
INTEGRATE CLIMATE RISK INTO THE
SAFETY ELEMENT OF THEIR GENERAL
PLAN.
AND SO WERE IN THE EARLY STAGES
RIGHT NOW OF IT WE HAVE PROVIDED
GUIDANCE.
BOTH. IN HOW TO DO THAT IN THE
SAFETY ELEMENT BUT THEN ALSO HOW
TO REALLY THINK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
GENERAL PLAN.
WERE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH A NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE. IMPLEMENTING SP THREE
SEVENTY NINE AND GOING THROUGH
THE SAFETY ELEMENT UPDATE
PROCESS NOW SINGLE MORTAR REPORT
ON THAT BUT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
HIS HANDS ON HIS WE CAN WAS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO DO THAT.
.
IN ADDITION WE POINT TO THE
SCIENCE IN THE TOOLS AT THE
STATE HAS PRODUCED SOME CLUED IN
THE ADAPTATION PLANNING GUIDE IN
KALIDAS. AND OTHER TOOLS TO
SUPPORT THAT WORK.
ANOTHER OVERARCHING OBJECTIVE WE
HAD WE UNDERTOOK THE UPDATE WAS
TO INTEGRATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND EQUITY INTO THE
DOCUMENT OVERALL. AGAIN EYES
SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND PASSED
WHILE WE WERE OUT WORKING ON THE
UPDATE. AND SO FOLLOWING WE'RE
IN THE MIDST OF DOING A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC OUTREACH
AROUND THAT AND WILL BE
RELEASING AND BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR.
REVISED GUIDANCE ON
IMPLEMENTATION.
.
I MENTAL JUSTICE.
I SHOULD SAY THAT GENERAL PLAN
GUIDELINES UPDATE PROCESS.
TOOK A NUMBER TOOK SEVERAL
YEARS TO DO IT WAS BASED ON A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT. AND
INPUT.
AND WE'VE CREATED A DOCUMENT
THAT I WE HOPE IS SUPPORTING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT ALSO ONE
THAT WE CAN UPDATE AS NEW
INFORMATION BECOMES AVAILABLE.
AND MAKE IT EASIER FOR FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE WHAT
DOING THEIR GENERAL PLAN WORK.
.
AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF OF HOW
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS ALSO THROUGH.
A GROUP CALLED THE ALLIANCE OF
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE'S FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION OR ARCA.
AND THIS IS BEEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT WAY FOR US TO WORK
WITH LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS IS
PORT. CLIMATE ADAPTATION THEY
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE UPDATING THEIR
GENERAL PLANS.
.
BUT ARCA INCLUDES MEMBERS FROM
SEVERAL MAJOR REGIONS AROUND THE
STATE INCLUDING.
SACRAMENTO THE BAY AREA A LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO THERE ARE.
.
COLLABORATIVE SWARMING IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE INCLUDING THE
INLAND EMPIRE AYE AND THE
CENTRAL COAST.
AND THIS IS BEEN A REALLY
IMPORTANT WAY FOR US TO HEAR
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
THINK ABOUT HOW THE WORK WE'RE
DOING CAN SUPPORT WHAT'S
HAPPENING. I'M AND REALLY.
CREATE BETTER ALIGNMENT.
ANOTHER AND IT INITIATIVE THAT
WE'VE BEEN UNDERTAKING AT OPR IS
THIS THEN THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY PROGRAM. AND THIS IS
CREATED THROUGH LEGISLATION
THROUGH SENATE BILL TWO FOUR SIX
SIX WHICH WAS CITED A LOT IN
AYE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WHAT YOU CALL
THIS AYE CARP BECAUSE WE NEED AN
ACRONYM FOR EVERYTHING.
THEIR TWO PRIMARY ELEMENTS TO
THIS PROGRAM ONE IS A TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COUNCIL.
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED THAT
INCLUDES STATE REPRESENTATION
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS AND
PRIVATE SECTOR MEMBERS.
.
BUT IT WAS REALLY ESTABLISHED TO
FACILITATE COORDINATION ACROSS
STATE LOCAL AND REGIONAL EFFORTS
AROUND CLIMATE ADAPTATION.
WE MEET QUARTERLY.
IN A PUBLIC VENUES WE HAVE
PUBLICLY NOTICE AND I MEETINGS
AND.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE PUBLICLY
NOTICE WORKGROUP MEETING.
.
THEY WERE EVEN MEETING AROUND
THE STATE AYE WE JUST STARTED
LAST YEAR SO WE'VE HAD FIVE
MEETINGS TO DATE. AND WE'VE
TAKEN ON A SEVERAL TASKS AS A
GROUP.
THE FIRST WAS THAT ADOPTED THE
ADOPTION OF A VISION AND SET OF
PRINCIPLES FOR ADAPTATION ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS THAT TECHNICAL
VICE THREE COUNCIL NOTED. WAS WE
ALL WANT TO SUPPORT ADAPTATION
BUT WE NEED A BETTER IDEA AND
RESILIENCE A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT
IS IT THAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS.
AND IT'S HARD TO SET A
QUANTITATIVE TARGET FOR THAT AND
SO WE AS A GROUP DID WAS ADOPTED
A VISION AND A SET OF PRINCIPLES
FOR ACHIEVING THAT VISION. AND
THAT VISION REALLY LOOKS AT A
VERY HOLISTIC.
APPROACH WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE RESILIENCE OF NOT JUST OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT OF OUR PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES AND OUR NATURAL
SYSTEMS.
AND HOW DOES ALL WORK TOGETHER
AND ULTIMATELY TO ACHIEVE A
STATE OF RESILIENCE WE NEED TO
THINK ACROSS ALL OF THOSE.
PIECES.
AND THEN.
AND THEN WITH THAT WE'VE IN
THING ABOUT HOW IS IT THAT WE
TRACK OUR PROGRESS OF BUILDING
OFF OF SAFEGUARDING US WORK AND
THOSE ACTIONS. HOW IS IT THAT WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
FROM PLANNING THROUGH TO
IMPLEMENTATION?
ANOTHER ELEMENT OF THAT WORK
HAS BEEN AROUND PROTECTING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS CALLED OUT.
IN EXECUTIVE ORDER B. THIRTY
FIFTEEN WHICH GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED IN APRIL TWENTY FIFTEEN
SO I CALLED OUT AND SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA MENTIONED IN THE
PANEL PREVIOUSLY BUT. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE REALLY
PRIORITIZE PROTECTION OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
CALIFORNIA? AND SO RECENTLY.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO DEFINE
WHATTHAT LOOKS LIKE AND SO WHAT
IS IT THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
VULNERABILITY IT'S NOT JUST
EXPOSURE TO CLIMB AT RISK. SOME
OF THE INHERENT CHARACTERISTICS
OF POPULATIONS IN LOCATIONS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO VULNERABILITY.
AND SO WE ARE WORKING TO
FINALIZE SOME RESOURCE MATERIALS
THAT CAN HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND OTHERS TO THINK ABOUT HOW
HOW TO CONCEPTUALIZE AND PROTECT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND THAT WILL FEED INTO THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF THE AYE CAR
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AN ADAPTATION CLEARING HOUSE.
AND SO. I THE CLEARINGHOUSE IS
BASICALLY IS A A RESOURCE THAT'S
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
AGENCIES IN IMPLEMENTING AND
DOING ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
WORK ON THE GROUND. IS INTENDED
TO BRING TO A CENTRALIZED.
.
PORTAL ITS ONLINE TOOL.
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INFO.
SOURCES OF INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN ACCESS OR STATE AGENCIES ARE
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS.
.
SO IT'S WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
UC BERKELEY TO DEVELOP THIS TOOL
IT'S REALLY USER FRIENDLY
DATABASE.
THAT YOU CAN SEARCH THROUGH
DEBT NUMBER OF DIFFERENT MEANS
YOU CAN GO IN AND LOOK AT A
TOPIC. YOU COULD LOOK AT A
CERTAIN IMPACT IMPACT YOU CAN
ALSO ACCESS ALL THE INFORMATION
THROUGH A MAP INTERFACE IF YOU
WANTED TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN YOUR REGION OR IN YOUR
COUNTY.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF RESOURCES IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE INCLUDING
ASSESSMENTS
GENERAL PLANS GUIDANCE
COMMUNICATION EDUCATION
MATERIALS.
CASE STUDIES AND OTHER EXAMPLES
IN ADDITION WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING A SET OF SMALL FIRST
PERSON NARRATIVES.
THAT JUST EXPLAIN HOW PEOPLE
ORDERED ARE DEALING WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE EITHER ON AN INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL OR WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THAT'S CLEARING HOUSE WAS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO
HIGHLIGHT RESORT AND CONNECT
THESE RESOURCES SO IT TIES
DIRECTLY INTO CAL ADOPT WHICH
HOUSES ALL OF THE CLIMATE DATA
INFORMATION FOR. THE SAME AS
WELL AS THE ADAPTATION PLANNING
GUIDE AND OTHER.
SUMMARIZE GUIDANCE DOCUMENT THE
GENERAL PLAN GUIDELINES
ETCETERA I THE CLEARINGHOUSE IS
CURRENTLY IN A BETA TESTING
PHASE II AND THE WEBSITE IS
RESILIENCY A DOT ORG.
AND SO. WE DOES DESIGNED IT
AFTER A NUMBER OF USER NEEDS
WORKSHOPS AROUND THE STATE AND
WITH STATE AGENCIES AS WELL. AND
UTILITIES AND OTHERS ARE AS OF
TODAY ARMS THROUGH MID MARCH WE
HAVE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY RESOURCES IN THAT.
CLEARING HOUSE AND THERE ARE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
FOR EVERY SECTOR EVERY REGION
AND EVERY IMPACT AREA.
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF RESOURCES
AT THIS POINT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
CHO SIN OCEANS AND SEA LEVEL
RISE GUIDANCE. AYE BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL WHO HAD A
SIMILAR DIRECTIVE TO MAKE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
SEA LEVEL RISE PLANNING. SO
RATHER THAN BUILD TWO SEPARATE
DATABASES WE DECIDED TO WORK
TOGETHER AND MAKE ONE.
AND SO THAT IS ALL HOUSED IN
THIS CLEARING HOUSE.
LOOKING AHEAD WE'RE LOOKING AT
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THE LONG
TERM VIABILITY OF THAT RESOURCE.
AND THE UTILITY OF THE CLEARING
HOUSE SINCE THAT'S GOING TO
INCLUDE THE INTEGRATION OF NEW
MATERIAL AS IT BECOMES AVAILABLE
INCLUDING ALL OF THE STUDIES
FROM THE FOURTH CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT.
LINKING IT TO STATE INVESTMENTS
AS APPROPRIATE SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CALTRANS TO BRING
IN INFORMATION ON THE SP ONE
ADAPTATION PLANNING GRANTS EVERY
GRANTEE WILL BE. SUBMITTING CASE
STUDIES THAT WILL BE HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE CLEARING HOUSE.
WILL ALSO BE JUST REGULARLY
CURATING AND UPDATING IT SO THAT
WE GET RID OF OUT OF DATE
MATERIALS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
NEWEST INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE.
I'M IN THAT TOOL.
AND SO OVER ALL OUR EFFORTS
HAVE REALLY BEEN AROUND ENSURING
AND MAKING OUT TO MAKE RESOURCES
AND TOOLS AVAILABLE AND TO
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
THEY ARE UNDERTAKING THE WORK TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO I'LL CONCLUDE THERE AND THEN
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS LATER.
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GARCIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I'M
DOCTOR KAREN SMITH THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'M I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT.
THEY THE PUBLIC HEALTH RISKS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH THE
PREVIOUS PANEL ALSO TOUCHED ON
BUT ALSO WITH THE DEPARTMENT IS
DOING IN THIS AREA.
COMEY CHANGE REALLY DOES POSE
SIGNIFICANT THREATS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH INCLUDING DIRECT EFFECTS
LIKE SOME OF THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER INCREASES
IN AS MY CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
FROM INCREASING AIR POLLUTION.
INJURIES.
DEATH AND.
OTHER IMPACTS OF SEVERE CLIMATE
EVENTS BUT ALSO TO.
IMPACTS ON MENTAL HEALTH OF
INCREASING A CLIMATE EVENTS AS
WELL PARTICULARLY SEVERE STORMS
AND THINGS ACROSS DISPLACEMENT.
OTHER LESS OBVIOUS THREATS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH FROM GLOBAL
WARMING IN PARTICULAR THOSE LIKE
CHANGES IN VECTOR ECOLOGY WHICH
HAVE RESULTED IN THE MIGRATION
OF. EIGHTIES EGYPT I MOSQUITO
THE CARRIER OF BOTH SEEK A VIRUS
BUT ALSO YELLOW FEVER A MUCH
MORE SERIOUS VIRUS. INTO THE
SOUTHERN UNITED STATES INCLUDING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THESE SAME ECOLOGICAL IMPACTS
ARE ON HUMAN HEALTH WILL HAVE
MUCH MORE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES
ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD OBVIOUSLY
WITH IMPLICATIONS FOR FOOD
SHORTAGE.
AND.
DIFFICULTY. WITH CLEAN WATER
MALNUTRITION DOTS AND SO ON.
CLIMATE CHANGE THOUGH IS
AFFECTING CALIFORNIANS THAT I
THE PREVIOUS PANEL SPOKE ABOUT
THIS BUT I THOUGHT WHAT I WOULD
DO IS GIVE YOU A FEW NUMBERS
JUST TO PROVIDE SOME.
CONTEXT IT WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
.
DOCTOR RICH SPOKE ELOQUENTLY
ABOUT EXTREME HEAT AND THE
CHALLENGES OF EXTREME HEAT.
THAT'S PROBABLY AREA WHICH IN
CALIFORNIA WE SEE THE GREATEST
DIRECT LOSS OF LIFE AND ILLNESS.
THERE ARE TWENTY TO SIXTY HEAT
RELATED DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA
EVERY YEAR IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THERE WERE FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO HEAT RELATED
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS
THESE ARE NOT INSIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS.
HE ILLNESS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS PEOPLE WHO WORK OUTDOORS
AND THE ELDERLY AND IS ALSO HAS.
BEGINNING CHAU IAN LINKS TO
INFANT MORTALITY THAT'S AN AREA
THAT NEEDS MORE DATA THAT WERE
WORKING ON.
LAST YEAR'S WILDFIRES OBVIOUSLY
ALSO LEAD TO INJURIES DEATHS AND
INCREASED RESPIRATORY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR ILLNESSES.
AND COMMUNITIES ALSO SUFFERED
FROM IMPORTANT INDIRECT IMPACTS
OF OF FIRES INCLUDING PROPERTY
LOSS RESIDENTIAL DISPLACEMENT
LOSS OF JOBS.
IT'S OVER AND THIS HAS. UMPS
PROFOUND IMPACT NOT JUST ON THE
INDIVIDUALS BUT THEN ON THEIR
FAMILIES MOVING FORWARD THROUGH
TIME.
PEOPLE ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING.
INCREASING.
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS FROM.
FROM CLIMATE EVENTS.
.
LET'S SEE HIM.
WE DID A SURVEY.
IT OF RESIDENTS AMERICA CENTRAL
LARRY COUNTY DURING.
AND AND IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
FOUR YEAR DROUGHT
THE JETS KIND OF THE REALLY
INTERESTING CASE STUDY BECAUSE
IT'S SUCH A LONG AND DRAWN OUT
EVENT.
IN SAVED WE WE'VE SURVEYED
RESIDENTS IN MARIPOSA AND TULARE
COUNTY AND FOUND THAT BETWEEN
SIXTEEN TO FORTY SIX PERCENT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS. EXIT EXACERBATE HAD
EXACERBATIONS OF THEIR HEALTH
CONDITIONS DURING THE DROUGHT
AND OVER A QUARTER HAD NEGATIVE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON THEIR
PROPERTY AND FINANCES WHICH HAS
EVEN GREATER. LONG TERM.
EFFECTS ON THE ENTIRE FAMILY
I'M WE'VE ALSO SEEN WORSENING
AIR QUALITY AND INCREASE RISK
RELATED TO WEST NILE VIRUS
HANTAVIRUS AND VALLEY FEVER. AS
WELL AS I'M EXHILARATED
SALTWATER INTRUSION ON FRESH
WATER SOURCES.
.
I THIS IS BEEN MENTIONED BY
SEVERAL PEOPLE THAT FOR US AND
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH OUR FOCUSES ON
HEALTH EQUITY IN ENSURING THAT
EVERYONE HAS EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES
TO LIVE A HEALTHY LIFE AND AND
WITH. THE GREATEST WELLNESS
POSSIBLE INCREASINGLY THOUGH
WHAT WERE SO WE SEE THAT THE
RISK FROM CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT
EVENLY DISTRIBUTED SOME
POPULATIONS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY VULNERABLE
AND IN PARTICULAR. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
YOUNG CHILDREN OLDER ADULTS
PREGNANT WOMEN OUTDOOR WORKERS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED.
OR WITH WHO HAVE CHRONIC
MEDICAL TO CONDITIONS INCLUDING
MENTAL ILLNESS.
THESE ARE POPULATIONS THAT ARE
FACING CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS
THAT EXACERBATE ALL OF THOSE
SAME VULNERABILITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE SOME COMMUNITIES COLOR
MORE LIKELY TO RESIDE IN AREAS
WITH MORE PAYMENT LESS PARKS
ENTRY CANOPY WE'VE HAD AN
EXCELLENT DISCUSSION BY DOCTOR
ROADS FOR URBAN HEAT ISLANDS.
THE EXISTING INEQUITIES IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE IN WHICH
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES LIVE.
ARE THEN JUST EXACERBATED.
I'M THE SAME COMMUNITIES ARE
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE AIR
CONDITIONING FOR EXAMPLE AND
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE ONE
OR MORE OF THE CHRONIC DISEASES
THAT THAT. ARE SO PREVALENT IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
YEAH DPH WE'VE LONG RECOGNIZE
THAT THE DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND.
ON VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
THAT THEY WILL WORSEN THE
EXISTING HEALTH INEQUITIES AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE CLIMATE CHANGE AND HEALTH
EQUITY PROGRAM. IS ACTUALLY
HOUSED IN OUR OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY BECAUSE EQUITY IS AT THE
HEART OF FOR US.
OUR WORK AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THE PROGRAM TOUCHES. OVER IT
VIRTUALLY EVERY OF OUR TWO
HUNDRED PLUS PROGRAMS IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
ARE BUT OUR EFFORTS ARE LARGELY
FOCUSED AROUND MITIGATION
ADAPTATION OF A LITTLE BIT OF
RESEARCH
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
STATE AGENCY PARTNERS I'M OUR
HEALTH AND ALL POLICIES PROGRAM
ALSO DOES IT A LOT OF ACTIVITIES
THAT RELATE DIRECTLY TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. I WANTED IS HIGHLIGHT
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE WORK THAT WE
DO AND THAT'S THE CAL GRACE
CALIFORNIA BREAK.
.
BUILDING RESILIENCE AGAINST
CLIMATE AFFECTS PROGRAM WHICH IS
FUNDED BY A GRANT FROM THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION AND THAT WITHOUT TO.
WORK IS FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS.
IN PARTICULAR TO BUILD CLOUT
CLIMATE ADAPTATION CAPACITY AND
ENHANCE RESILIENCE BOTH AT THE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVELS THE
TOOLS THAT CAO BREEZE I AM HAS
DEVELOPED. ARE DESIGNED TO
ENABLE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
INCORPORATE BOTH CLIMATE
PROJECTIONS AND EPIDEMIOLOGY
DATA WE WORK IN EPIDEMIOLOGIC
DATA AT NEAR DISEASE DISTRICTS
DISTRIBUTIONS ETCETERA ALL THE
TIME IT'S AT THE CORE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH DOES. WHAT WE
TRIED TO DO WITH CAL BRACES THAT
ALSO OVERLAY THAT WITH WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES WHICH ALLOWS US TO
BETTER?
CREATE TOOLS THAT THAT LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS CAN USE
THAT A
ADAPTATION PLANTS OR MITIGATION
PLANS FOR THEIR SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES. WE CREATED CLIMATE
VULNERABILITY PROFILES FOR
EVERY.
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE
THAT I'M BEING USED BY LOCAL
CULTURE STATIONS. TO HELP.
TO A UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
IMPACTS ARE AND BE WHERE WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITIES THOUGH IN
THOSE IMPACTS ARE LIKELY TO BE
GREATEST. THEY ALSO OVERLAPS
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH THE.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS TRAIN.
PROGRAMS BOTH AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AS WELL AS WITHIN PUBLIC
HEALTH BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF
FEMA'S REQUIREMENTS FOR YOUR
EMERGENCY.
PLANS YOUR OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT.
THESE KINDS OF OF EVENTS HE'S
KIND OF CLIMATE VULNERABILITIES.
AND SO WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH COUNTIES TO I'M TRYING TO
HELP THEM. YUM WE ALSO LEVERAGE
SOME OF THEIR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS SPENDING WHICH THEY
GOT THROUGH CDC VIA THIS THE
DEPARTMENT. TO WORK ON
SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THESE
CLIMATE.
VULNERABILITIES.
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT CAO
BRACES ALSO DEVELOPED.
SOME NEW DATA VISUALIZATION
TOOLS USING GIS MAPPING TO
REALLY HONE DOWN WITHIN
COMMUNITIES WHERE.
.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE LIKELY
TO GET THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK IN TERMS OF.
WHETHER IT'S URBAN GREENING OR
OTHER KINDS OF.
IMPACTS WEEK IN SOME WAYS HAVE
A LEG UP IN PUBLIC HEALTH
BECAUSE VIRTUALLY.
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO TO.
COMBAT A CHRONIC DISEASES SUCH
AS OBESITY HYPERTENSION AT
CETERA ARE THE SAME THINGS THAT
YOU DO IN ORDER TO MAKE
HEALTHIER ENVIRONMENT AND. TO
HELP PROTECT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE SO. I'M ALL LEAVE IT AT
THAT AND TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU ALL OF GO BACK TO YEAH
UNDERSECRETARY TERMS OF THE.
FULL PARTICIPATION OF OLIVER
AGENCIES DID WORK WHERE THERE
ANY OF THE. AGENCIES THAT
PERHAPS DIDN'T.
SEE FIT AND YOU KNOW THERE.
SITEMINIS COLLINS KATE THAT IT'S
HARD SO THERE MAY BE RIGHT THERE
MAY BE BECAUSE THERE ARE NO.
THEY'RE SO SO WITHIN EACH AGENCY
AYE I CAN SAY THAT THERE WERE
THERE WERE DEFINITELY.
.
YOU KNOW THE THAT.
AGENCIES THINK ABOUT THEIR THEIR
MISSION AND THEY THINK ABOUT
THEIR DAY TO DAY JOBS IN TERMS
OF WHAT OF WHAT DO THEY NEED TO
ACHIEVE. TO TO TALK TO MISSION
SO IF YOU'RE WORKING IN WATER
FLOODING THE DO WITH LEVEES. YOU
KNOW AS AN EXAMPLE D. W. OURS
DID A REALLY GOOD JOB OF OF
BRINGING IN CLIMATE.
CLIMATE INFORMATION TO INFORM
HOW THEY PLANNED FOR FLOODING IN
THEIR MODEL FOR THIS.
OTHER OTHER AGENCIES.
YOU KNOW ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
THINKING ABOUT.
WHAT'S THE COME TO THEY DON'T
THINK ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THEY JUST THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF. WHAT KIND OF
PAVEMENT DO WE NEED TO APPLY IN
THIS REGION SINCE WE KNOW THE
TEMPERATURE MIGHT BE GOING UP?
IN THAT PAVEMENT MIGHT NEED TO
BE REQUIRED JUST SO YOU KNOW I
CAN'T.
I CAN'T YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT ONE
AGENCY THAT REALLY DIDN'T DIDN'T
RESPOND TO US BUT I AM OF THE
BEAUTY OF THE PLANET YOU CAN YOU
CAN LOOK AT AND STAKEHOLDERS CAN
LOOK AT AND SAY. THIS IS
COMPLETELY DEFICIENT DO YOU NEED
TO DO THIS THE SURPRISE IT'S A
SO THAT'S ACCOUNTABILITY OR THIS
IS GREAT. OTHER PEOPLE SHOULD BE
DOING THIS THIS AND THIS ITS AND
I I JUST I JUST LOOK AT IT FROM
A PERSPECTIVE OF.
.
I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE IN MY
DISTRICT AND I THINK IT'S VERY
RELEVANT BUT I STILL. HAVE TO
WORK ON CONNECTING THE DOTS TO
FOLKS.
MY CONSTITUENCY ON WHY MATTER
EDUARDO IS WORKING ON CLIMATE
CHANGE ISSUES.
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH AND. THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE DEGREE
DAYS.
YOU KNOW DURING THE SUMMERTIME
CLEARLY CAN THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THAT
RIGHT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE AIR
QUALITY PROBLEMS THAT EXIST IN
OUR DISTRICT AND CERTAINLY.
ADDING TO THE ANOTHER
JUSTIFICATION Y.. AT THESE
ISSUES ARE IMPORTANT TO ME AND
SHOULD BE TO EVERYONE IN THE
DISTRICTS SO.
YOU KNOW THERE COULD BE AN
AGENCY THAT SAYS YOU KNOW I.
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCY IT COULD
SAY. HEY YOU KNOW WE DON'T
REALLY DEAL WITH THAT BUT YET
THERE'S EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
YOU KNOW.
ELEMENTS TO HAVING TO ADDRESS
THE FLOODING ISSUES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED EARLIER RIGHT OR THE.
YOU KNOW THE HEAT STROKE.
COMPONENTS RIGHT THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN WILL INCREASE.
THE NEED FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES
AT A HOSPITAL SO I JUST.
CURIOUS WHY BECAUSE THERE WOULD
ALWAYS BE SOMEONE WHO MAY LOOK
AT IT FROM A PERSPECTIVE. OF
WHAT THEY DO AND ONLY WHAT THEY
DO AND SAY.
THAT DOES NOT REALLY AFFECT US
AND SO WE'RE NOT. NEEDING TO
PARTICIPATE BUT I APPRECIATE
THEM THE ANSWER IN.
I GUESS ALL OF YOUR PARTNERS
THAT THE AGENCY SHOULD FEEL GOOD
THAT THEY HAVE SOMEONE LIKE YOU
NOT THAT NINE THEM UNDER US. SO.
KUDOS TO YOU HOW HARD.
I WANT TO.
TO YOU KNOW THE AND MENTIONED
EARLIER COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE RECOGNIZE AND AS
I'VE BEEN UP HERE THE LAST THREE
YEARS. AND WE PASS POLICIES TO
GIVE OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
MORE TOOLS RIGHT COME MORE TOOLS
TO DO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WHETHER IT BE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCE DISTRICTS OR OTHER.
ELEMENTS THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT AND SELDOM REALLY.
DO ANY OF THESE JURISDICTIONS
AND I CAN SPEAK FOR THE ONES IN
MY DISTRICT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THEM SO I'M WONDERING. HOW ARE
WE DETERMINING IF IN FACT OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS?
TO QUESTION FOUR OP ARIAS'S AYE
WE SEEN. FOLKS ACTUALLY GONNA
COME AND.
BEGIN USING THE RESOURCES THAT
YOU'RE DEVELOPING YOUR SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME ENERGY AND
RESOURCES AND REALLY
CONSOLIDATING.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION.
AND TOOLS.
ARE WE LOOKING AT THIS AT THE
END OF THE YEAR EVERY TWO YEARS
AND SAYING. OKAY PEOPLE ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK WE DO TRACK
OUR PROGRESS AND OF HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING IN OF
COURSE.
WITH THAT AS WITH STATE AGENCIES
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT AND HOW
THEY APPROACH IT THIS SUMMER.
GOING OUT.
VERY AGGRESSIVELY IN AND SOME
YOU HAVE TO PULL ALONG A LITTLE
MORE I THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOTE IS YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE IS ALSO DO WE DON'T
WANT TO JUST PUSH INFORMATION
OUT. AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WE CAN'T JUST THROW INFORMATION
AND TOOLS OUT THERE AND EXPECT
FOR THEM TO BE TAKEN UP. IT'S A
TWO WAY STREET AND I THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THROUGH.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GENERAL
PLAN GUIDELINES THROUGH THE
INTEGRATED CRIME ADAPTATION
RESILIENCY PROGRAM IS CREATE
MORE OF THAT BACK AND FORTH SO.
IT'S NOT A GOOD USE OF OUR TIME
AND RESOURCES OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TIME AND RESOURCES
IF WE'RE NOT LISTENING TO ONE
ANOTHER. SO I THINK.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW ARE
THEY USING TOOLS WHAT ARE THEY
TRYING TO DO.
SO WE CAN BETTER PROVIDE
INFORMATION RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW AND THEN AND CREATE A
VENUE TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE AS
WELL BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
ALSO A LOT WE CAN LEARN FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND THAT'S
WHY IT WOULD I MENTION THE
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE'S REALLY
HELPFUL FOR US TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
SO I I THINK WE ARE THE ANSWER
IS YES WE'RE SEEING PROGRESS
WE'RE SEEING INFORMATION BEING
TAKEN UP BUT THERE'S WORK TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
LISTENING TO ONE ANOTHER AND
CONTINUING TO PREP PROVIDING.
YOU KNOW THE RIGHT SUPPORT AND
AND HEAR WHAT THEY'RE DOING SO.
YEAH PLEASE ADDED AND I PUT THIS
IN THE BEGINNING OF MY POINTS
AND I THINK YOU ALSO NEED.
USE YOUR LITTLE YOUR LEVERS TO
PUSH CERTAIN LOCALS TO DO THESE
THINGS OUT AND AND WITH OUR WITH
THE WITH THE BUDGET IN THE STATE
IS AND WITH THESE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES IN BOTH. YOU KNOW
S. B. ONE FUNDS POTENTIAL PROP
SIXTY EIGHT PRIOR BOND FUNDS
DIFFERENT FUNDING MECHANISMS
HERE WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO TO PUSH AND
PULL THESE GUYS EVEN. AGREED
RIGHT I THINK FOR FOR US A.
AND THE LIGHT BULB GOES ON RIGHT
WITH MY FORMER COLLEAGUES.
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT. WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL OF
THESE RESOURCES ARE BEING
ALLOCATED IN THE SPECIFIC AREAS.
WHAT COMES TO MIND IS YOU KNOW
A CITY THAT'S IT WILL SAY YOU
KNOW WE WE ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THOSE DOLLARS BECAUSE OF? X. Y.
AND Z. REASONS IN PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
ASSERTIVE.
PLANNING. GOING INTO A LINING
WHAT THEY'RE DESIGNING AS A.
PLANNING EFFORT IN THE COMMUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO THEN.
.
ALIGN THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS RIGHT FOR. THESE
OPPORTUNITIES IS. AS SIMPLE AS
YOU KNOW UPDATING THE GENERAL
PLANS IN INTEGRATING THESE
OTHER ELEMENTS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COULD POTENTIALLY.
LEAD TO SOME OF THESE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES AYE THAT WE'RE
JUST TALKING ABOUT SO.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
DO STILL.
IN OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND OUR REGIONAL.
COGS OUT THERE THAT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
RESPONSIBILITY I MEAN YOU KNOW I
SIT ON THE. A ARE BE BORED AND
WE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO ABOUT. YOU
KNOW THE EXPECTATIONS OF OUR
REGIONAL PLANNING AGENCIES TO
HELP IN THIS MEET SOME OF OUR
REDUCTION GOALS. OVERALL IN
THINK THIS ALL FALLS IN LINE
WITH THE CONVERSATION.
THE WAR HAVE BEEN.
NUMBER ONE TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
THE EXTREME HERE YOU KNOW FOR
US.
BEING ABLE TO MEASURE YOU KNOW
OUR EFFORTS INVESTMENTS IN A
PLACE LIKE IMPERIAL COUNTY THAT
HAS SIGNIFICANTLY. A POOR AIR
QUALITY AND THE HIGH LEVELS OF
COURSE THE OUTCOME OF THAT
MEANING HIGH LEVELS OF
RESPIRATORY DISEASE. PROBLEMS
AMONGST CHILDREN AND ADULTS YOU
KNOW WE'D LOVE TO GET YOUR TAKE
ON HOW WE MAY BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS.
.
THE INFORMATION GAP AS IT
RELATES TO THE INVESTMENTS MEAN
MADE AND THEN ULTIMATELY THE
OUTCOMES THAT REDUCING. YOU KNOW
THE AMOUNT OF VISITS TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM BAD THAT ARE
RELEVANT TO RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS
ARE MAKING YOU KINDA MAYBE
ELABORATE AND SEE.
WHAT OTHER WAYS THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO INTEGRATE SOME KIND OF
BENCHMARKS FOR US TO BE ABLE? TO
DETERMINE YOU KNOW OUTCOMES OF
OUR EFFORTS.
I THINK THAT.
WE DID AND WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ADVANTAGES AND THE DISADVANTAGES
TO WE DO HAVE.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION ON HEALTH ON
PARTICULAR HEALTH INDICATORS
AND.
SUE AND WE HAVE SOME TOOLS TO
ACTUALLY FOLLOW THOSE OUT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY RA AD IN CURRENT
STATE SO FOR EXAMPLE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT VISITS WERE. ACTIVELY
WORKING RIGHT NOW TO PURSUE THE.
THE IT TECHNOLOGY THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE MUCH MORE REAL TIME
CURRENTLY WE'RE SORT OF ALWAYS
WORKING.
ANYWHERE FROM.
IF WE'RE LUCKY A MONTH TO SIX
MONTHS BEHIND TO WE CAN DO LOTS
OF RETROSPECTIVE LOOKING AT.
TRENDS OVER TIME AND TRYING TO
DRAW CONNECTIONS BETWEEN
COMMUNITIES I THINK THAT.
AN ADVANTAGE THAT WE HAVE IS
WITH OF THE VARIOUS NOW METRICS
OF HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WERE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO BRING TOGETHER
BOTH. ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS
BUT ALSO HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
OTHER OTHER.
ASPECTS THAT WE KNOW CONTRIBUTE
TO OVERALL HEALTH THINGS LIKE.
ECONOMICS IN EDUCATION AS WE'VE
BUILT THESE SORT OF COMPOUNDED
INDICATORS OF HEALTH WE CAN
BEGIN TO LOOK AT THE EXTERNAL
PRESSURES THAT MAY MOVE THAT
OVER ON THAT INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE CRAPPIE CLIMATE CHANGE
EFFECTS TOO. FOR.
FOR EXAMPLE.
MONITORING HOW COMMUNITIES ARE
DOING IN TERMS OF THEIR CHRONIC
DISEASE AFTER OF AFTER ACUTE
EVENTS IS HELPING US TO PREDICT
WHAT WE MIGHT SEE.
IN COMMUNITIES AFTER NOON KNEW
ABOUT SO EVERYTHING WE LEARNED
ABOUT THE TROUT FOR EXAMPLE WE
NOW HAVE IDEAS OF WHAT THINGS
NEED TO BE IN PLACE. AND THEN WE
CAN MEASURE THAT PROACTIVELY
THROUGH A NEW EVENTS BUT REALLY
IT'S GONNA TAKE A LITTLE. I
THINK WE'RE SORT OF THREE YEARS
THREE TO FIVE YEARS FROM REALLY
MAXIMIZING THE DATA THAT'S
INTERIOR AVAILABLE. I'M SO THAT
WE CAN.
GET AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE TO TIE AT LEAST HEALTH
A FAX.
TO.
THE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND RESILIENCY OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD HOPE TO SEE. YOU IF WE CAN
PROJECT WHAT WE THINK WE MIGHT
SEE AND WE SEE LASSEN A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS INVESTED A
LOT IN RESILIENCE WE MAY
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO TIE SOME OF
THAT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. DATA.
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO BE.
FOCUSING ON THAT WE MAY NOT BE.
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT RIGHT
NOW AYE IN THESE QUESTIONS THAT
THEY. ARE ASKED BY A TOOL MY
COLLEAGUES ON THAT THEY ARE BE.
YEAH AS WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS
MORE SPECIFICALLY. IT IN AREAS
WHERE WE KNOW WHERE QUALITY IS
POOR WE. HAVE NOW PUSH FORWARD
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE LOCAL
IT QUITE DISTRICTS TO DO JUST A
LITTLE MORE. RIGHT WITH THE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTEEN.
AM.
BUT THEY'RE WANTING TO SEE HOW
WE GOING DETERMINE YOU KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THESE EFFORTS SO.
SO.
IN SOME WAYS AND AS FAR AS
HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AIR QUALITY IS ALMOST THE
EASIEST TOO BECAUSE YOU CAN YOU
SEE VERY IMMEDIATE EFFECTS
SO WITH AS WITH AS MAY
EXACERBATIONS BUT. ALSO AS WE
BUILD OUT OUR ABILITY TO GET MY
CLOSE TO REAL TIME INFORMATION
FROM OUTPATIENT CLINICAL
SETTINGS NOW WE CAN START
LOOKING OUT. EXACERBATIONS VERB
IN PEOPLE WHO HAVE HEART DISEASE
FOR EXAMPLE. WE KNOW THE EFFECT
IS A LARGE BUT WE HAVEN'T YET
BEEN ABLE TO MEASURE IT AND SO I
THINK THAT AND THOSE ARE
SPECIFIC VERY SPECIFIC TO
PARTICULATE MATTER AND OZONE
TYPE.
EVENTS AND PATTERNS OVER TIME
SO.
IT IF WE HAVE IF WE HAVE THE
ABILITY BOTH THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING YOU
KNOW WHAT THE LEVELS OF
PARTICULATE MATTERS ARE OVER
TIME. AND WE CAN MAP CERTAIN
HEALTH INDICATORS SUCH AS
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE ASTHMA
EXACERBATIONS ETCETERA WE MAY BE
ABLE TO HAVE MUCH GREATER
INFORMATION AND MORE ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON. WHAT INTERVENTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING IN THOSE CAN IT
IN THOSE SITUATIONS?
THANK YOU OTHER THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US.
AS THIS CONVERSATION IS A VERY
FRESH AND RELEVANT ONE THAT.
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
.
CONSIDERING THE LEVEL OF TENSION
AND INVESTMENTS.
THAT WILL BE PUT INTO THIS
PARTICULAR AREA.
ANY CLOSING. COMMENTS OR
THOUGHTS ON ON YOUR AND
UNDERSECRETARIES.
AND A WRAP UP THIS HEARING
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO ADD.
NO I AMENDING THE MESSES THAT
WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING A
LOT.
ACROSS ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
AND.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T FEEL SATISFIED
WITH EVERYTHING THEY WERE DOING
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR MORE
ANSWERS AND MORE YOU KNOW
CHALLENGES TO ADDRESS.
.
WE WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS IS ALL VERY NEW IS USE IS
YOU SAID THIS IS THIS IS NEW
WORK AND WE'RE LEARNING FROM
EACH OTHER SO. BEING AS HONEST
AS WE CAN ABOUT.
BEING OPEN TO CRITICISM AND
EVALUATION IS IS IS HEALTHY AND
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW I'D WE JUST APPRECIATE
ALL THE SUPPORT WE GET FROM.
FROM LEGISLATURE AND ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT AND IN THE WORK
THAT ARE DEPARTMENTS ARE DOING
UP TO TO TO PUSH IT FURTHER SO.
THANK YOU AND I THINK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING IN
OUR DISTRICT ALONG NOT.
EYES OF RELEASES SOLVENCY THAT
INTERSECT WITH ALL OF THESE
TOPICS THAT WE DISCOVERED TODAY.
AT ENDING ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NO I THINK THAT IS WHAT HAS
RAISED. THE PROFILE OF THIS
ISSUE.
STATEWIDE IN HAS HELPED US MOVE
THE NEEDLE ON SOME OF THE
WEATHER BE POLICY.
RELATED MATTERS WE WORKED ON OR
FOR THAT MATTER THE FUNDING.
COMPONENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE PROP SIXTY EIGHT SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN THE
SECRETARY AS WELL.
I THINK ANY THOUGHTS ON YOUR.
NO I THINK I MEG KALE AND ECHO
CAYLEY'S POINTS AND I THINK THE
KEY IS IT'S NOT JUST THAT WE'RE
PLANNING FOR A DIFFERENT FUTURE
AND WE KNOW THE FUTURE'S GONNA
LOOK DIFFERENT THAN THE PAST AND
TODAY.
BUT IS ALSO THAT WERE PLANNING
DIFFERENTLY AND I THINK THAT'S
REFLECTED IN HOW WERE
COORDINATED AND WORKING TOGETHER
ACROSS STATE AGENCIES BUT ALSO.
ACROSS THE STATE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL LEVEL AND WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AS WELL AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BECOME.
EVEN MORE CRITICAL.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU. SEARCHES OF AN ECHO
THE AND THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT
WAY OF DOING BUSINESS AT THE
STATE HAVE AGENCIES WORK AS
CLOSELY TOGETHER AS THEY DO.
AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO EACH OTHER ON
VARIOUS ASPECTS AND THAT REALLY
IS MODELING I THINK FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO.
SIMILARLY CREATE THESE KINDS OF
CROSS SECTORAL COLLABORATIVE'S
IN ORDER TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. KIND A RACE
PROFILE ON THESE ISSUES.
I THINK IN THIS AREA YOU KNOW
ALONE AND THAT'S PROBABLY
HEARING ON ITS OWN WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THE RECENT FIRES IN THE
IMPACTS.
SPECIFIC A PARTS OF THE STATE
BUT. THE OVERALL IMPACTS IN THAT
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT WE BRING
BACK THE.
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER BUT
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING.
AND THAT THIS TIME I'LL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO ADDRESS.
.
THE COMMITTEE OF ONE TODAY.
MA ALL EARS.
THERE'S REALLY NOT A REASON TO
SET A TIME LIMIT THERE ARE A LOT
OF FOLKS HERE.
SO PLEASE.
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND.
.
EXECUTIVE ADDRESS YOUR COMMENTS
TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
I KNOW I WILL BE.
AND I CAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
STAFF ARE RICO MUSTERED ANOTHER
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
FIRST OF ALL I WANNA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND TALKING ABOUT
ADAPTATION I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS THIS ISSUE. OF
RESILIENCE AN ADAPTATION IS
GETTING IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
AT ALL SO BRINGS TO MIND THAT
THE EFFORTS THAT YOU'RE DOING
THROUGH THE BUDGET TO A TO HELP
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE.
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS THAT
WERE TALKED ABOUT BY THE
PANELISTS HAVING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT REALLY STAND OUT TO
ME FROM LISTENING TO THE
PANELISTS THIS AFTERNOON.
ARE.
FIRST OF ALL THE INTERSECTION
MENTALITY OF OF ALL THESE
INVESTMENTS IN AND WHEN YOU.
RESTORE YOUR FOREST'S YOU
IMPROVE YOUR WATER SUPPLY WATER
QUALITY AND.
SPECIES DIVERSE CITY WHERE YOU
GET A LOT OF BANG FOR YOUR BUCK.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT I THINK
WE WHEN WE LOOK AT INVESTMENTS.
ON ANY KIND OF INVESTMENT REALLY
BUT CERTAINLYCLIMATE
INVESTMENTS THING EVERYONE OF
THEM NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
THROUGH A SOCIAL EQUITY LINES.
WE'VE HEARD FROM YOU VIRTUALLY
EVERYONE THAT THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS IMPACTING DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
AND WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AND MAKE INVESTMENTS
ACCORDINGLY.
AND.
YOU KNOW THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC%
LAND WORKS AND.
BOTH
AND WILD LANDSCAPES IN THE
SIERRAS AND OTHER PLACES BUT WE
DO A LOT OF WORK AND THE URBAN
LANDSCAPE. AND WE KNOW WHEN YOU.
.
YOU KNOW BUILD IN URBAN GREENING
PROJECT AND.
YOU KNOW YOU PICK THE PLACE BUT
CLIMATE SOUTH LOS ANGELES
COACHELLA. YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT
ONLY REDUCING HEAT MITIGATION
OR.
HEAT ISLANDS WHICH I THINK ARE.
THE MOST URGENT.
SORT OF HEALTH IMPACT WE HAVE
LOOKING AT OUR CLIMATE CHANGE.
.
AND BUT YOU GET ALL THESE CALL
BENEFITS AS WELL YOU KNOW YOU
GET THE HEAT REDUCTION BUT YOU
ALSO GET PERMEABLE PAVERS AND
YOU GO OUT. CAPTURE STORM WATER
YOU HAVE A PLACE TO WRECK RATE
SO KIDS CAN BE YOU KNOW HAVE A
HEALTHY YOU.
OUTDOOR LIFE IN AND OUT BETTER
CHANCE OF
OF OF OF FLOM BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
SO I YOU KNOW I THINK NATURAL
RESOURCE INVESTMENTS HAVE
HISTORICALLY AT LEAST THROUGH
THE GDR AFGHAN.
.
UNDER RESOURCE TO YOU NOW I
THINK WE'VE GOT MAYBE TEN
PERCENT OF THE GTR A FUNDS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE IS A
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF URGENCY TO
TO.
PIECE INVESTMENTS NOW WE CANNOT
WAIT WE CAN. YOU KNOW THERE'S
ARE THEREOF LITERALLY LIVES AT
STAKE SO.
AT ANY RATE I CAN APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'RE DOING IN YOUR GREAT
STAFF AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN.
ABOUT PAUL MASON PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST ALL ECHO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LANDS ACCOLADES IN APPRECIATION
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. AND IN THE BUDGET AND THE
GOOD WORK OF YOUR STAFF ON ALL
THE.
SUPPORT WORK FOR ALL THOSE
ACTIVITIES.
I WANT TO CIRCLE BACK AROUND TWO
WEEKS AND THEN A FAIR AMOUNT
TIME EARLIER TALKING ABOUT WATER
AND WATER AT THIS FOR THE
CONSUMER AND OF THE SPECTRUM.
BUT I THINK IT COULD BE TERRIBLY
IMPORTANT AS WE START LOOKING
OUT TO MID CENTURY AND LATER. TO
BE.
PLANNING NOW FOR THAT WATER IS
GOING TO BE COMING FROM.
BECAUSE AS YOU LOOK AT HOW
CLIMATE CHANGE IS LIKELY TO
AFFECT CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW GENERALLY SPEAKING
COULD BE HOTTER AND DRIER IN THE
SOUTH STAY RELATIVELY SPEAKING.
MOISTER AND RELATIVELY SPEAKING
COOLER AND THE NORTH WHICH IS
GOING TO REALLY.
INCREASED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THOSE WATERSHEDS IN THOSE SOURCE
WATER AREAS WHERE SO MUCH OF
THE.
ON THE WATER THAT WE END UP
UTILIZING FOR AGRICULTURE AND
FOR URBAN USE FARTHER SOUTH. YOU
KNOW COMES FROM OROVILLE SHASTA
IN THE WATERSHEDS DEFEAT IN
THERE AS WELL AS THE REST OF THE
SIERRA.
AND AS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT.
INVESTMENTS
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING
THOSE WATERSHEDS BACK INTO THE
SORT OF CONDITION WHO WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THEM AND IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. IS GONNA REQUIRE
FRANKLY THIRTY YEARS OF WORK TO
GET THERE BECAUSE THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGES JUST SO.
EXTENSIVE BUT IT PAYS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DIVIDENDS YOU
MENTIONED.
.
YOU KNOW THE.
CONVERSATION WITH HUNGER ON FIRE
AND FOREST CONDITIONS A LOT OF
THOSE ISSUES AND.
YOU KNOW FOR KATIE SAKE I WON'T
TALK ABOUT THOSE TOO MUCH.
RIGHT NOW BUT WILL HIGHLIGHT
THIS IN OUR WATERSHED
RESTORATION GOES BEYOND JUST WE
NEED TO DO FOR OUR FORESTS IT'S
ALSO RESTORING MEADOWS AND.
STREAM CHANNELS AND REALLY
TRYING TO GET US BACK TO THE.
RESILIENT CONDITION WHERE WATER
IS RELEASED FROM THOSE AREAS.
LOOKING FARTHER OUT INTO THE
SUMMERTIME AND MORE EVENLY
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO THAT WE
DON'T JUST HAVE THESE BIG
FLUSHES COMING DOWN FRANKLY
RIGHT ABOUT NOW. AS WEARING
THESE WARM DAYS BUT THAT WATER
IS METERED OUT LATER INTO THE
YEAR. THAT AMOUNTS TO CREATING
AN. ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL STORAGE.
FOR OUR WATER BECAUSE WATER
COMING INTO OUR RESERVOIRS LATER
INTO THE YEAR IS JUST AS GOOD IS
HAVING A BIGGER RESERVOIR. AND
SAW AS I WAS NOW LOOKING AT THE
NEWS EARLIER I SAW. AND KNEW OP
ED FROM SECRETARY LAIRD TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD ON STORAGE I WOULD JUST
REALLY HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF BENEFIT TO BE HAD IN THE
WATERSHED RESTORATION.
TO INCREASE CAPACITY AND IMPROVE
TIMING.
FOR WATER THERE.
AND NOT SOLELY AND BUILD
STORAGE.
SO ONE OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE MAKING SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS COMMITTEE TO THEM
OVER TIMES WE CAN ACTUALLY PLAN
TO BE GETTING TO SCALE ACROSS
MILLIONS OF ACRES CENTER AND
PART OF OUR WATER SUPPLIES.
SMEAR REALLY IMPORTANT.
.
STEP TOWARDS GETTING.
WORK DONE AT THE LEVEL THAT WE
NEED TO OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
CAPTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ANONYMOUS BRANCH OF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AGRICULTURE
NETWORK.
AND.
SECTOR I JUST FIRST ONE OF THE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND NOTE THAT PERSONALLY YOUR
ELOQUENT DISCUSSION OF CLIMATE
IMPACTS IN YOUR DISTRICT.
WHETHER THE COURSE OF MANY
HEARINGS LAST YEAR INSPIRED ME
TO COME VISIT YOUR DISTRICT LAST
DECEMBER.
AND THERE'S REALLY NO.
BETTER PLACE TO LOOK AT AND
THINK ABOUT COMING IMPACTS THAN
MARKING ON THE SALTON SEA.
AND THINKING ABOUT THE WATER
AND HE WAVED CHALLENGES THAT
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS NEAR
DISTRICT FACE.
SO APPRECIATE CONVENING THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY.
.
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
FINDINGS FROM A RECENT STUDY
THAT CAME OUT ON CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS A IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. THIS WAS DONE BY
FIVE YOU SEE PROFESSORS.
.
AND.
THERE'S A LOT BUT JUST A COUPLE.
IT HIGHLIGHTS A WERE EXPECTING
A FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE IN
SEVERE DROUGHTS BY THE END OF
THE CENTURY.
.
HEAT WAVES WE KNOW WILL DECREASE
YIELDS AND TOMATOES FOR A RICE
AND WINE GRAPES.
I WILL ALSO EXPECT REDUCE
QUALITY AND.
STRAWBERRIES AND GRAPES IN
TERMS OF THE FRUIT.
AND THEN.
MILDER WINTERS WILL INCREASE
PASSED RANGING REPRODUCTION
AFFECTING A NUMBER OF KEY CROPS
IN THE STATE.
.
SO THE REPORT ALSO HELPFULLY
LISTS ADAPTATION STRATEGIES FOR
A LOT OF THOSE CHALLENGES.
BUT I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT.
.
THE PRACTICE IS FUNDED BY THE
HEALTHY SOILS AND THE SWEET
PROGRAM.
.
ARE LISTED IN EVERYONE OF THE
CATEGORIES OF CLIMATE IMPACT
SINCE AND ASSOCIATED STRATEGIES.
AND SO.
I'D I JUST REALLY WANNA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR AG RECOGNITION OF
THAT NEXUS BETWEEN SWEEPING
HEALTHY SWELLS. KINDA CHANGE
IMPACTS NOTATION I IN YOUR
FIGHTS FOR INVESTMENTS IN THE
CABIN TRADE.
PROGRAMS AND OF THE BOND OF THE
DOLLARS.
HE DID ASK ABOUT GAPS.
IN SORT OF PLANNING. AND ONE
THAT I WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
I'M IS TALKED ABOUT IN THAT
REPORT THAT THERE ISN'T
CURRENTLY STATE POLICY FOR. IS
TO HELP FARMERS AND RANCHERS
AND.
DO YOU BUSINESS PLANNING AND
LAND SUCCESSION PLANNING.
AROUND THE ISSUE OF CHANGING
CROP AND.
RANGES SO WE KNOW THAT COPS ARE
GONNA GENTLY AFTER SHIFT NORTH.
AND.
SO FARMERS GOING TO BE NEEDED
TO CHANGE.
BOTH CROPS AND PRODUCTION
METHODS OVER THE NEXT FEW
DECADES.
THAT COULD HAVE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS FOR FARMERS.
.
ESPECIALLY THOSE LOOKING TO HER
LIKE RETIRED THEY MADE THEY MAY
END UP JUST DECIDING TO GET OUT
OF THE BUSINESS AND SELL THEIR
LAND OVERALL. AND THAT WOULD
HAVE BIG LAND USE IMPACTS SO.
I'M WE ARE INTERESTED IN A
CONVERSATION AROUND HOW TO
ASSIST THE PRIVATE SECTOR AG
INDUSTRY IN.
PLANNING FOR.
SUCCESSION OF CROPS AND LAND.
BUT THANK YOU OVER OFFICE.
GOTTEN IN CHAIR AND.
COMMITTEE STAFFS AND FOR OTHER
OF ON THE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA RELIEF.
I MEAN MY COLLEAGUES HAVE IT
REALLY KIND OF.
VERY ELOQUENTLY STATED ALL THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE ALL
SUPPORTING.
THIS DISCUSSION REALLY HAPPY TO
SEE THE CONVERSATION THAT'S
HAPPENING.
AND YOU KNOW FROM IRVING
GRADING TERM FORESTRY TO
WETLANDS RESTORATION EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT THAT YOU'RE
CHAMPIONING TO YOUR BUDGET
REQUEST. AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN
SEE A LOT OF THE THESE GROUPS
YOU PREACH ACQUIRE MANY WAYS.
BUT GETTING BACK TO THE
QUESTION OF GAPS.
THAT YOU RAISED ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WITHIN THE RIBBON
FOR CHIC.
BUT THURMOND AND COMMUNITY
FORCE PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR THROUGH
LEADERSHIP OF.
LEARNING GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
UPDATING THAT URBAN FORESTRY
ACT TO INCLUDE ALL THE THE
DIVISIONAL COURT BENEFITS NOT
JUST FOCUSED ON CARBON
SEQUESTRATION BUT. THE STORM
WATER CAPTURE AND IN THE STORM
WATER MANAGEMENT ASPECTS OF
URBAN FORESTRY IN URBAN
GREENING.
EVEN GOING TO SOME OF THE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AND HOW YOU YOU
ENSURE THAT AS YOU'RE DEVELOPING
DISCREET PROGRAMS MAKING IS
GREAT INVESTMENTS.
THE THE IMMEDIATE BENEFIT OF THE
PROJECT IS GOING TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITY BUT EVEN BETTER WOULD
BE FOR THE COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD IT THEMSELVES.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE THING
THAT YOU KNOW. THEY HOPE I'M
ICED I MISS THE AGENCY
DISCUSSION I HAD TO STEP UP A
LITTLE BIT BUT.
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THEY'RE CONSIDERING
AND AND AND AND ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW AS YOU HEARD FROM
CALIFORNIA RELIEF.
DURING THE LAST HEARING.
THERE IS A LOT OF COOL WORK
BEING DONE ALREADY IF THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE LEVEL TO
ENSURE THAT THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS ARE LOOKING AT THAT
ISSUE SPECIFICALLY ARE ARE BEING
FULLY FLESHED OUT AND
IMPLEMENTED.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOT I MEAN I KNOW
WITHOUT A BY CALIFORNIA SAME.
AS MY PREVIOUS COLLEAGUE I
WANNA ECHO EVERYTHING THAT MARK
EVERY SPEAKER BEFORE ME HAD SAID
OF. OUR ORGANIZATION REALLY
WORKS ROUTE ACROSS THE STATE
FROM EVERYWHERE FROM THE SOUND
SEE ALL THE WAY TO YOU KNOW THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND AND WETLANDS
AT RESTORATION WITH FARMERS.
TRYING TO.
APPLY FOR A FARM FAMILY
PRACTICES THAT I HAVE CO
BENEFITS THAT ALLOW A BIRD
POPULATIONS TO. ADAPT AND.
HOPEFULLY SURVIVE THE AYE AYE
CHENEY CLIMATE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
WE WOULD.
REALLY LIKE IT THE.
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY IN A
AND WE'VE HAD SOME LEVEL OF
DISCUSSION AROUND THIS IS THAT
ARE HAVING AN INVENTORY OF LANDS
A PUBLIC LINES TO SEE. HOW?
THOSE AGENCIES WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
IN MANAGING THEM ARE.
ADAPTING.
FOR.
CHANGING CLIMATE AS WE AS WE
START TO SEE OF THE POPULATION.
AS WE SAW.
IN ONE OF OUR RECENT STUDIES.
.
THE HABITAT.
CHANGING IN MIGRATE NORTHWARD
AND SO I THINK THAT HAVING SO
SOME SOME OF THOSE INVENTORIES
ON PUBLIC LANDS. ASIDE I THINK
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO.
MAY MANAGE AND AND AND HELP THE
AGENCIES REALLY TRY TO COME UP
WITH A STRATEGY THAT IS
BENEFICIAL TO EVERYONE. THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL OF YOU WHO PARTICIPATE ON
THE PANEL THOSE OF YOU WHO SPOKE
A.
THIS LAST SEGMENT OF OUR HEARING
WE APPRECIATE YOU ATTENDING AND.
CONTINUOUS CONVERSATION THAT
FURTHER ALONG WITH ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS THANK YOU.
MANAGER